good morning today we will complete the
opening submissions of the core
participants and then turn to hearing
evidence
Mr Bowie I'm sorry I
threw off yesterday
thank you milady
and good morning everyone
the following opening statement is made
on behalf of Public Health Scotland or
PHS for short
at the outset we wish to say that we're
very grateful to the inquiry for its
considerable work in getting to this
important milestone
the start of the module one hearings
and for how our having been afforded an
opportunity to participate in and
contribute to this module of the
inquiry's work
we are well aware it is only by dint of
the huge amount of work and effort by
you my lady Council to the inquiry and
the rest of your team
that the core participants including PHS
and The Wider public are now on the
verge of being able to listen to the
first of many important witnesses to
this inquiry give their oral testimony
in short
PHS is grateful and pleased to be here
on this historic and important day
PHS it's legal team and I look forward
to participating over the coming weeks
in these hearings and assisting you my
lady and your team in whatever way we
can
PHS sincerely believes it has much to
contribute and share by way of
experience and expertise
but equally important From phs's
perspective we are here to learn
to learn from the inquiry what can be
done better to protect the people of
Scotland from future threats to their
health
PHS is committed to that
for several months now PHS has been
working hard to produce all of the
information the inquiry has asked of it
to date the organization has produced
detailed statements chronologies
narratives and other documents across a
number of the inquiries modules
it's hope the documentation produced has
been informative and assisted the
inquiry in gaining and gaining a fuller
understanding of who PHS is and the work
it does
during this process we have been we have
very much been speaking to the inquiry
and although as a result the inquiry
will know we hope have a much better
idea of who PHS is we're very conscious
that the wider public who are watching
and listening today may very well not
hence in this opening statement our
strong desire and intention is to speak
not only to the inquiry but to the
public also
in particular the Scottish public
especially those who have an interest in
the work of phas
it goes without saying that I am very
much also speaking to the Scottish
covid-19 bereaved families for justice
who have such an important place in this
inquiry
it is our hope that what I say today is
helpful to all of those with an interest
in phas
I want to see something now about PHS
the organization
Public Health Scotland is what's termed
a special Health Board and is the lead
National Organization in Scotland for
improving and protecting the health and
well-being of Scotland's population
it was created after a public health
reform program in Scotland which was
designed amongst other things to
strengthen National leadership in public
health
the organization draws upon a range of
expertise within its staff to deliver
these objectives including Health Care
Consultants nursing staff and Healthcare
scientists
Health social care policy and funding
including Public Health policy are
devolved matters
this means that PHS operates in a
different context to its counterparts in
the other UK Nations
PHS is committed to helping the inquiry
navigate the complexities that this will
inevitably create for a uk-wide
investigation
in terms of its relationships with
others
PHS is accountable to both Scottish
government and local government
reflecting the fact that public health
in Scotland is viewed as a shared
Endeavor of both local and national
government
indeed PHS is uniquely sponsored by
Scottish government and the convention
of Scottish local authorities kosla on
behalf of local government
on the day-to-day level PHS collaborates
across public and third sectors
it's important to note that PHS is a
relatively young organization it came
into existence legally in December 2019
becoming operational on first April 2020
at around the start of the pandemic and
at the time of the first uk-wide
lockdown
it will be apparent that consequently
During the period with which this module
of the inquiry is concerned PHS was not
operational
responsibility for protecting the
Scottish public from infectious diseases
and environmental hazards fell to a
different organization
Health protection Scotland or HPS for
short
when PHS was created many of the staff
and functions of HPS were transferred
over to PHS
moreover it's important to understand
that because of the pandemic at the time
of phs's launch they're required to be a
rapid rethinking of a number of plans in
relation to the organization which had
been put in place over a number of years
previously
it's fair to say that the organization
faced a number of coalescing and
difficult challenges at that time
despite the pressure of being very much
on the front line of the nation's
response to dealing with the pandemic in
September 2020 PHS published a
three-year strategic plan setting out
its goals for Scotland focusing on four
cross-cutting areas covid-19 community
and place poverty and children and
mental well-being
the original strategy was strengthened
in November
2022 with the publication of a new
three-year plan
this plan built on the 2020 strategic
plan and set out phs's purpose as
Scotland's national public health body
to lead and support work across Scotland
to prevent disease prolong healthy life
and promote health and well-being
PHS publicly stated values include
respect collaboration
Innovation excellence and integrity
PHS undertakes that going forward it
will continue to do everything in its
power to assist the inquiry with its
work in whatever way it can
it will endeavor to approach the inquiry
with openness respect and candor
underpinned by a genuine desire to learn
and do better
as a public body phas understands the
responsibility it owes not only to the
inquiry but to the people of Scotland
and it will do everything it can to meet
those responsibilities
thank you for listening thank you very
much
now I think it's
it's sister Hill
foreign
I represent the government office for
science
it is right to acknowledge at the start
of this inquiry the enduring loss
suffered by those affected by the
pandemic
those bereaved as a consequence of
covid-19
those who were separated from their
loved ones
and were not reunited
those who continue to live with the
life-altering effects of long covered
it is also right to acknowledge for
wider public who took their own
altruistic steps to counter covert 19.
those who volunteered for clinical
trials
those who supported vulnerable people
during lockdown
those who curtailed their own lives and
businesses to help protect others
the government office for Science and
the current and former government Chief
scientific advisors for whom we speak
wish to commit publicly
to what we understand to be the common
goal of those participating in this
inquiry
to examine what happened in order to
inform and improve the country's
Collective response to Future pandemics
in these brief opening remarks we
thought it may assist to deal with two
topics
first an overview of what the government
office for Science and Sage are and
perhaps just as importantly what they
are not
and second an outline of a work that has
been done to learn lessons from the
pandemic and some of the themes that
have been identified in that work
turning to the first of these topics
the government office for science go
science as it's known is a small
organization
at its head is the government's Chief
Scientific Advisor the gcsa who reports
to the cabinet secretary
together go science and the gcsa provide
science advice to the Prime Minister and
the cabinet and promote and support the
provision of science advice in all
government departments
during government-wide emergencies go
science convenes and provides
Secretariat support for sage the
scientific Advisory Group for
emergencies
Sage is generally chaired by the gcsa
during the pandemic it was co-chaired by
Sir Patrick Valance then gcsa and the
chief medical officer sir Chris Whitty
Sage is not a permanent standing
committee and it does not have members
it exists only when it is activated by
cobra in response to an emergency
its role is to bring together experts
relevant to that emergency to inform
science advice in a way that is
coordinated
comprehensive
and comprehensible
those who participate in sage and its
subgroups are experts drawn from across
the country
from inside and outside government
those who attend give independent advice
their analysis drawn from their
expertise and experience
it is important to note a few key points
first
go science for gcsa and Sage are not the
only formal sources of science advice to
government even during an emergency
different government departments
different government departments lead on
different areas which are related to
their own work and expertise
as we have heard for pandemic planning
the Department of Health and Social care
is the lead department and draws on its
own network of scientists clinicians
Public Health experts and so forth to
inform its work
most government departments have their
own Chief scientific advisors and their
own structures and processes by which
science advice is provided internally to
senior civil servants and ministers
organizations such as the United Kingdom
Health Security Agency provide
operational science and advice
sage and the gcsa Do Not could not and
would not wish to establish a monopoly
on science advice
second
the gcsa and Sage do not make policy
they provide evidence and advice to
policy makers Who weigh it against other
sources of evidence and advice economic
legal ethical political
and on occasion National Security advice
in order for policy decisions to be made
in our democratic system elected
politicians make those decisions and in
making them are accountable to
Parliament and to be electorate
during the pandemic at sir Patrick's
insistence Sage published its minutes
and its papers
other areas of advice were not made
public and thus were not subjected to
the same level of debate and scrutiny
a potential consequence of sages
transparency may be that the science
advice arising from Sage was given
particular prominence in the minds of
the media and the public in relation to
policy
it was of course an important input
but it was never the only consideration
nor should it have been
third
the gcsa and Sage are not responsible
for the operational delivery of science
for example establishing a testing
program
nor are they responsible for the way in
which the science advice is implemented
in practice
for example putting in place procedures
to lessen the risk of infection in
schools hospitals or Care Homes
those matters fall to other departments
and other organizations
fourth the processes I have described
are intended to deal with all aspects of
science advice in government at all
times
it must not be forgotten but most of the
work of the gcsa and go science relates
to a wide variety of non-emergency
matters
further the pandemic was atypical even
for an emergency situation and was
unprecedented in its duration
there were 105 Sage meetings over two
years
the most previously was 22 over seven
months
the scale and duration of the response
posed challenges and appoints reveal
vulnerabilities in the way in which sage
and go science operated
that brings me to the second topic
Lessons Learned
the work of a gcsa and go science on
critical self-examination and challenge
began the early stages of a pandemic
in April 2020 Professor sir Ian Boyd was
invited to observe Sage meetings in
order to provide for chairs with
feedback on groupthink optimism bias and
other matters
this was followed shortly after by a
review undertaken by Sir Adrian Smith
now president of the Royal Society at
the request of Avenged gcsa
these were the first of many reviews all
of which are set out of a witness
statements provided to the inquiry
the work is ongoing in the form of the
sage development program which is
designed to embed the Lessons Learned in
ways of working
a number of documents papers and reports
touching on a wide range of matters have
been produced and brought to the
inquiries attention
two may be considered to be a particular
significance
the first is the technical report of the
covid-19 pandemic in the UK published on
the 1st of December 2022 but was
produced by the chief medical officers
and others including Sir Patrick
the second is the Hundred Days Mission
the document produced under sir
Patrick's leadership as part of the UK's
presidency of G7 which addressed the
specific question of how to accelerate
for Discovery and development of
Diagnostics vaccines and Therapeutics
go science will listen carefully to the
evidence that is reduced and that
evidence and your leadership's reports
will inform its further work
it maintains an open mind
it may be helpful though to share some
of the initial observations that have
emerged from the work undertaken to date
this is not intended as an exhaustive
list and it is restricted to matters
relating to science and science advice
rather than a wider assessment of
factors that affected the course of a
pandemic
first the existence of sage and its
subgroups was beneficial to the UK's
response
not every country had an equivalent of
sage and many of those that did not
sought to emulate it
second
while there may be an argument to
establish equivalent advisory groups on
matters such as economics
Sage should continue to concern itself
only with science
it will be better for sage and any
additional groups to convene separately
and present their distinct outputs to
politicians and decision makers
it is for them and not be experts to
waver competing factors against one
another
make the trade-offs and come to
decisions on policy
third
those scientific areas in which the UK
was strong going into the pandemic with
those in which it did well
the quality and breadth of its science
space
expertise in genomic sequencing
expertise in Pharmaceuticals and
vaccines and the ability to mount
large-scale National clinical trials
conversely
areas of national weakness led to
vulnerability
the absence of a major domestic
diagnostic industry and difficulties in
scaling up the manufacture of
Diagnostics
the underlying health inequalities and
comorbidities within the UK population
the lack of excess capacity in the NHS
even in normal times
and challenges in scaling and operations
of a public health infrastructure which
raise questions about the investment
made in that system in preceding years
and whether it responded effectively to
previous pandemic threats
you have heard from others the need to
address weaknesses
we agree
and would add that there is also a need
to maintain strengths including advances
made during the pandemic
fourth and related
access to Reliable and relevant data is
critical in responding to a pandemic or
indeed any major emergency
initially this was an area of weakness
data were not available or were not
shared or could not be collated and
analyzed rapidly
this hampered advice and resulted in
under-informed decisions
this weakness was addressed and data
collection usage and presentation
improved markedly
a central question for this inquiry and
for society as a whole is to determine
which data will be required in the event
of an emergency
how they can be shared and how to
establish and maintain structures to
achieve this
your leadership will see that these
observations reflect the three themes of
100 days mission
timely and continued investment in
research and development
maintaining capacity and best practice
by embedding it in everyday work and
agreeing in advance for rules of the
road for example on which data is to be
shared and how
these do not purport to be an entire
answer to how to prepare for a pandemic
but they are a necessary starting point
finally it would not be right to
conclude without acknowledging the
extraordinary efforts of many scientists
academics and clinicians who assisted
sage and its subgroups
the workload was formidable and the
pressure intense
they stepped forward voluntarily and at
considerable cost to personal and family
lives
they did so not for personal advancement
or financial gain
but to help
their work saved many lives and the
country was fortunate to be able to call
upon them
unless I can assist her for my lady
that's very helpful thank you Mr Hill
right now I think it's Miss scolding
I should just wait my lady for the wait
for the passing of the lectern
good morning my lady I appear together
with Mr Stein Casey and we represent the
Department of Health and Social care in
this inquiry
we wish to start by expressing our
heartfelt condolences and deepest
sympathies to all the families who have
lost loved ones to this pandemic had
their lives disrupted and who have
suffered the after effects on both their
mental and physical health
the pandemic touched every family in the
nation and in many cases brought change
losses or absences which can never be
fully repaired
the department recognizes that the
guidance it put in place often meant
that family and friends were unable to
see their loved ones for long periods of
time causing profound loneliness pain
and anguish the effects of which still
endure for many today and were so
powerfully reminded To Us by the
accounts given in the video yesterday
in particular people were unable to
visit and comfort loved ones who were
unwell or dying and were unable to
undertake the important rituals
surrounding death which are so vital for
catharsis and expressing a shared grief
not being able to attend and Say Goodbye
at a family funeral was a nightmare for
so many of us the stoicism and
forbearance shown and the sacrifices
made by so many will never be forgotten
the department also wishes to thank each
and every person working within its own
staff
in Health and Social care in hospitals
Care Homes and in the community in
public health bodies in local government
in the armed forces in Charities and the
voluntary sector as well as the hundreds
of thousands of family carers who sought
to keep their loved ones safe at
considerable cost to their own physical
and mental health in very many cases the
dedication and compassion shown by these
individuals at very short notice and the
efforts they made to provide comfort and
support were nothing short of heroic and
we salute them
we must also thank each and every person
who changed their behavior to protect
those who are most at risk of being
affected by the pandemic the advice the
department gave and the measures it was
required to recommend needed the consent
of the population
everyone who stayed at home often to the
detriment of their mental health their
Financial Health their education and
their personal and professional
relationships helped keep us all safer
without this agreement many more people
would have lost their lives the
resilience determination and Swift
response by the population made a
tremendous difference
the aim of the department and those
working in it was at all times to save
lives minimize serious illness and
protect Health and Care particularly
during the first six months of the
pandemic when less was known about the
virus and its transmission there was
frequently a need to issue guidance or
create policies where there were in
reality no good options
the department recognizes the strength
of feeling amongst some that certain of
the decisions made by us were wrong for
example some people feel that lockdown
should have been introduced earlier and
for longer others hold an opposite and
contrary View
what the department was often faced with
were a choice between a series of hugely
unpalatable options all of which were
certain to have negative impacts on the
citizens of the United Kingdom in one
way or another
decisions were often extremely finely
balanced contrary decisions could
rationally have been made resulting in a
very different set of outcomes the
department will not seek during the
course of this inquiry to say that it
did everything right or that it would
necessarily have made the same decisions
today in 2023 with the benefit of
hindsight we will however propose that
it is necessary to recognize that the
context of the time particularly in
respect of pandemic preparedness was
very different to what we know now and
would ask you my lady not to impose what
we shall call a retroscope upon decision
making
covid-19 has not gone away the
department and all of those providing
Health and Social care in Britain are
still fighting it even though effective
vaccines and treatments mean that its
impact is very much reduced there are
new variants which require further work
to be undertaken and people are still
becoming ill sometimes seriously those
with clinical vulnerabilities are also
leading more restricted lives in some
cases the after effects of covid are
profound on the mental and physical
health of the nation as I've mentioned
and not least on those whose treatment
may have been paused for other diseases
and illnesses because of the pandemic
the job of the department is to remain
Vigilant and to keep caring for those
who require it
I shall not my lady be setting out a
detailed framework of the Department of
Health and Social care to which I have
no doubt many people shall be relieved
our role is predominantly to support
ministers to help people lead more
independent healthier lives for longer
its job is to set in place the framework
so that our NHS can function and deliver
exceptional Health Care to the
population and to provide care services
for the most vulnerable in our society
the organizational framework for
delivering such is complex and dispersed
amongst a large number of bodies in
central government in arms-length bodies
related to central government in local
government in charitable voluntary and
for-profit organizations
at the time of the pandemic for example
there were 152 local authorities
213 Hospital trusts
191 clinical commissioning groups 34 000
general practitioners and around 25 and
800 registered adult social care
establishments by which I mean both
domiciliary I.E non-residential and
residential services
the demands on both Health and Social
care services have increased greatly
over the past 20 years as people live
longer and breakthroughs in treatment
and Technology enable those with
disabilities to thrive in an Ever
broader range of activities
seeking to manage and provide guidance
support equipment services and policies
during the pandemic was a Herculean task
and was the greatest challenge ever
faced by the NHS and the adult social
care sector you will hear the department
referring to various documents as battle
plans or operations precisely because it
was an all-consuming period akin to a
war and mobilization was required in
every organization in the United Kingdom
and with every person we approach this
inquiry with humility we know that there
are valuable lessons to be learned we
are open-minded to learn what others say
about our processes and procedures both
before and during the pandemic and the
decisions we took
by the end of 2020 everyone was
thoroughly sick of the word
unprecedented but that is the most
accurate description of what happened
this module is dealing with the plans
that were put in place in advance of
that period of time
before the pandemic started they were
regarded by various International bodies
as World leading
some of those plans did help during the
pandemic and our evidence to this
inquiry points out where that is the
case an obvious example was the work
which had been undertaken following the
Ebola outbreak in 2015 to put additional
money into vaccine research and the
setting up by the previous chief medical
officer Dame Sally Davies of the
National Institute for health research
which brought together an aided research
funding again enabling a vaccine to be
developed quickly by the UK scientists
operation cygnus which was the exercise
you heard about yesterday undertaken in
2016 about planning for a flu pandemic
was also instrumental as it allowed the
United Kingdom to have draft legislation
which was then easily adapted for use
during 2020.
however the department does wish to
identify areas where in particular it
has sought to learn from what went well
and also what did not go well in respect
of preparedness
to enable it to prepare better for
future pandemics and other catastrophic
risks to the nation's health and
well-being these are best encapsulated
by the following five issues
first we need a toolkit of capabilities
which can adapt to deal with whatever
public health risk emerges rather than a
fixed plan against specific threats or
viruses plans are important but they are
only as good as the core capabilities
upon which they are based this is the
case for all measures which need to be
taken during pandemics for example the
provision of scientific advice research
surveillance and data the development of
vaccines Diagnostics testing and
Therapeutics the system of regulation of
medicines and medical products
stockpiles of medicines vaccines and
other material including PPE the
maintenance of manufacturing capacity
for testing Therapeutics PPE and other
pieces of equipment and Medicine which
is cited within the United Kingdom and a
legislative framework to enable action
actions to be implemented swiftly areas
where the UK has relative strengths
performed well during this pandemic
where there was weakness or fragility
the response was not as good
the under secondly the underlying
resilience of the Health and Social care
system really matters because a strong
system of Public Health and Social care
is needed to fight future risks
effectively indeed a resilient system
limited health inequalities and a
generally healthy population will be
more likely to be able to cope with
shocks of any kind levels of core
capacity for day-to-day Health and Care
Services which must be resilient need to
include specialist Laboratories which
can be expanded to meet demand rapidly
NHS General critical and intensive care
beds with bed occupancy levels at a
sustainable level and appropriate and
safe Staffing there is also a need for
social care services both at home and in
residential settings to maintain a high
level of built-in resilience for there
to be a good pipeline of medical
supplies and for a Workforce with the
experience and numbers to cope the
underlying health of the population and
health inequalities also matter in the
ability of our country to respond to new
health threats for example the
increasing age profile levels of obesity
smoking or pre-existing comorbidities
third any pandemic planning must include
the ability to Surge and scale up
quickly in the first few months planning
for preparedness and response capability
in the future must address areas which
have to be prepared in advance for
example stockpiles of antivirals
stockpiles of therapeutic measures
stockpiles of PPE whilst we learn more
about the disease and start to develop
specific Medical countermeasures
planning must also consider provision in
areas wherein an immediate response is
required for example the ability to buy
disease-specific vaccines or to
establish large-scale trials very
quickly we need to consider how we cope
in the first few months of a pandemic so
that our resources can be mobilized
effectively and scaled up to meet the
country's needs fourth diagnostic surge
capacity was a particular weakness in
the past pandemic the initial scientific
and Technical responses by way of
genomic sequencing of the virus and the
development of the test was good
reflecting our exceptional scientific
communities hard work and collaboration
our end position of being able to
provide over one million tests a day was
amongst the best in the world but it was
very difficult to scale up testing in
the first stages of this pandemic to the
number and speed required and it was an
area of significant weakness compared to
our International competitors and
comparators
fifth pandemic preparedness in the
future should take account of and be
responsive to all five routes of
transmission of communicable disease
respiratory touch oral blood or by
Vector for example an insect covid-19
and flu are both respiratory diseases
the last major pandemic within the UK
was HIV which was sexually transmitted
and required a very different response
and unfortunately there is still no
effective effective vaccine for it we
need as Professor van Tam infamously
said very many shots at the goal the
next time round
we must recognize that future pandemics
will be unexpected and will present new
challenges we need to be prepared for
the worst by maintaining the resources
and core capabilities that underpin a
resilient Health and Care system and a
healthy population alongside contingency
arrangements to scale up quickly
the department recognizes that the role
of the government is not just to ensure
that the UK is prepared but also to
assist other countries with pandemic
preparation and support including
surveillance Therapeutics and vaccines
to limit the spread of future diseases
this is not entirely altruistic but must
be seen as part of the strategy to
protect the United Kingdom
finally the department is well aware
that many will argue that extra resource
in Health and Care is part of the answer
to improve pandemic preparedness
it is this Department's role to advise
on strategies and policies to help as I
have already said people live more
independent healthier lives for longer
and to deliver Health and Social care
support that they need in a way which is
of the highest quality efficient and
cost effective it is however the job of
the government as a whole to make and
Implement decisions on the level of
resourcing balanced against competing
demands from other departments in this
regard fiscal and economic resilience
will always be vital to the country's
ability to Resource the needs of its
citizens both in ordinary life and in
future crises of this nature in short
the department welcomes the work of this
inquiry recognizes its importance in
shaping future preparedness and in
assessing the numerous decisions taking
taken in meeting the demands of the
covid pandemic the department is here to
assist with the work of the inquiry in
whatever way we can and the department
is committed to making sure that this
country is ready to face the challenges
presented by any and all future diseases
thank you for listening thank you very
much indeed
uh Mr Kinnear
short transfer that time
my lady good morning I appear on behalf
of the Welsh government before you today
the pandemic touched the lives of
everyone but none more so than those who
lost loved ones as was so powerfully
demonstrated in yesterday's Impact film
The bereaved a rightly seeking an answer
to the question which lies at the heart
of this module were the governments of
the United Kingdom adequately prepared
for the covid-19 pandemic
the question is one that requires a
timely answer and it is a significant
achievement of this inquiry that module
one has been brought so swiftly to a
hearing the scale of the preparation by
the inquiry team and the court core
participants is considerable and it
bodes well for the efficient completion
of the hearings in line with the
timetable you have recently announced
as Mr Keith's opening statement
Illustrated the question about the
adequacy of this country's preparedness
will not be a straightforward one to
answer
much turns on an assessment of
structures policies and procedures in
the four nations and although although
they shared some institutional
arrangements and framework strategies
and policies such as the UK's 2011
pandemic influenza strategy
there were material differences between
them all and their application by the
devolved governments much will also
depend upon whether the assessment
contained in the UK National risk
register are that pandemic influenza was
the greatest risk confronting the
country was reasonable
in addressing the question whether the
UK was adequately prepared the Welsh
government has cooperated fully with the
inquiry and will continue to do so
scrutiny May sometimes be difficult even
uncomfortable but it is necessary that
is because fair that unsparing scrutiny
is vital to make sure that the four
nations of the United Kingdom are best
prepared for any future health emergency
the worst government made clear the
outset that it would play its full part
in helping and supporting the inquiry's
work to that end in addition to giving
very significant disclosure the Welsh
government has provided 18 statements in
module 1 alone five statements came from
present ministers including the first
minister of Wales and former ministers
and 13 were given by past and present
senior officials
their statements answer the questions
that the inquiry asked and each and
every one of the makers of those
statements is ready to help your work
further
indeed a number have been called to give
oral evidence in due course
as you know the Welsh government
statements address in detail the
resilience and preparedness structures
in Wales the NHS in Wales and its links
to preparedness and resilience and the
provision of scientific Technical and
medical information in Wales those
matters were addressed at length as well
as the inquiries questions about what
was considered to have worked well in
relation to preparedness and equally
what was thought not to have worked well
at the detail of those views will surely
be considered further in examination
the Welsh government did not wait for
the inquiries call for evidence and
hearings to examine what it worked and
what did not work
before the first wave of the pandemic
started to retreat in June 2020 the
Welsh government started critically to
examine its own response and to identify
recommendations for improvement
the resulting analyzes have all been
disclosed inquiry undoubtedly the
conclusions of those analyzes will
inform councils and inquiries
examination of Welsh government
Witnesses and your report in due course
the inquiries work may also be assisted
by the work of others who have analyzed
the substance of the Welsh government's
response to the pandemic for example
parliamentary consideration of the Welsh
government's response by the various
Committees of the Senate
reviews by Welsh regulatory bodies such
as estin the inspectorate of Education
and Training in Wales health inspector
at Wales the care inspector of Wales and
the equality and Human Rights Commission
and finally audit work carried out by
the independent Body Audit Wales
particularly in relation to PPE
the inquiry will undoubtedly examine
Welsh government Witnesses on the
substance of the lessons learned from
its responses to the pandemic and what
they may say about the strengths and
weaknesses of preparedness Arrangements
in January 2020. one theme which emerges
from the evidence is that those
arrangements provided a useful
foundation for the Welsh government's
response that said when the pandemic
started adaptability and flexibility
were required of decision makers and all
those responsible for carrying out the
response the inquiry will examine
whether the degree of adaptability and
flexibility that was required could or
indeed should have been reasonably
anticipated before
the inquiry will also rightly Shine the
Light on the extent to which detailed
consideration was given to the impact of
the pandemic and the response on health
and other inequalities
although the general impact on
vulnerable persons was considered it is
fair to say that more detailed work
could have been done to identify the
particular effect of a pandemic and this
response on those with particular health
or impairment issues as well as broader
socioeconomic inequalities
one important point that Mr Keith Drew
out yesterday is the question the broad
question of resilience that it's say the
country's ability to respond to and to
recover from a whole system emergency
such as kobit 19.
it is much more than an analysis of
structures policies and procedures
although they are important
it is concerned with whether the country
has invested sufficiently both in terms
of people and resources to weather and
recover from an emergency such as the
pandemic the Welsh government's evidence
makes clear that a central element in
its view of wells's resilience was the
policy of steadily increasing investment
in the Welsh NHS in the years before
and in an environment where austerity is
significantly Limited at the available
funding
that important point of context will be
a significant feature in the assessment
of preparedness
another feature of resilience was the
well-established and effective working
relationships that had developed between
the Welsh government local Health boards
and Welsh local authorities in the years
before the pandemic as was reflected in
the Welsh local government association's
submissions yesterday afternoon
those good working relationships were an
essential and necessary feature of
effective preparedness and they greatly
assisted the response of the pandemic in
Wales that too may be an issue that will
be explored in due course
the inquiries investigation in module
one is rightly alive to the overarching
political context in which the adequacy
of preparedness will come to be assessed
in the years before 2020 a significant
and arguably the dominant factor of that
context will be the preparations for the
United Kingdom's departure from the
European Union and in particular the
planning for a No Deal exit
the extent to which brexit-related
preparation and planning consumed the
attention of all four governments in the
UK from 2017 onwards cannot be
underestimated
it is clear that brexit preparations
were the reason why the work of the UK's
pandemic influenza review board was
substantially paused in 2018
that said it is also clear that
preparations for a No Deal departure
required both ministers and officials to
consider the consequences of a whole
system emergency work which bore fruit
when the pandemic struck
my lady Matt finally turned to the
question of recommendations
a fundamental part of this inquiry's
work is the formulation of efficient and
effective recommendations that put right
any deficiencies or flaws that are found
to exist
the inquiry provides an invaluable
forensic context in which to identify
and analyze the merits or proposed
measures
my lady will know better than most from
her experience at following the 77
bombings that some proposals May at
first blush seem attractive or indeed
consistent with a perception of common
sense but which on analysis are found to
be unlikely to address the identified
problem effectively or indeed transfer
the risk elsewhere or maybe even
heighten that risk consideration of
recommendations may not therefore be a
straightforward exercise how the inquiry
will identify and consider them will be
an important feature of your work in
which the Welsh government stands ready
to help
at this stage one matter which the
inquiry may wish to consider is whether
and if so to what extent
intergovernmental arrangements for the
sharing and commissioning of expert
advice may be improved
some institutional reforms have already
been implemented primarily addressed at
enhancing the nature and quality of
intergovernmental liaison between the
heads of government of the four nations
however the clear and consistent
evidence is that Welsh was unable to
draw more directly upon the UK
government's very considerable and
comparatively greater expert scientific
resources so as to better inform their
own decision making
my lady in conclusion we come before you
recognizing that there will be lessons
to be learned in relation to
preparedness finally thank you for the
work that you and your team have already
undertaken and for the very much more
substantial work that is to come the
Welsh government will continue to assist
inquiry in any which way it can
thank you very much indeed
now I think we have Mr Mitchell for the
Scottish government
and this is lectern handing very well
planned
good morning my lady
um I appear at these public hearings on
behalf of the Scottish government I
appear along with my juniors Fiona
Drysdale and Jennifer Nicholson white
and we are instructed by Caroline Beatty
of the Scottish government legal
directorate
my theme this morning is one of
commitment
commitment to the chair to the inquiry
process and to the people of Scotland
that commitment is to assist and to
cooperate with the inquiry
to listen to the evidence and to learn
lessons that might flow from that
evidence
before going any further on behalf of
the Scottish government I would like to
recognize the loss suffered by the
people of Scotland and The Wider UK
population during the pandemic
everyone suffered and many thousands
lost their lives that loss is felt
understood and acknowledged by the
Scottish government
indeed how could it be otherwise
the people of Scotland are resilient
they responded to the challenges of
covid-19 and together Scotland emerged
from the pandemic yet the cost was high
certain sections of Scottish Society
suffered more than others
legitimate questions arise as to whether
the suffering needed to have been quite
so great
the continuing goal of the Scottish
government is to build a resilient
Scotland that is able to protect all its
citizens
from risks that emerged to threaten the
safety of modern day Society
therefore let me repeat one of the
commitments that I have already given
the Scottish government comes here to
listen
and is eager to learn how its processes
structures and policies on preparedness
could be improved
let me say something about Scotland's
resilience system which Mr Keith touched
on briefly yesterday
the Scottish government has taken an
approach over many years to build
resilience capacity to deal with any
risks faced by the country
including preparing for a pandemic
the Scottish government approached
pandemic risks and the way that it
approached any risk
often it prepared in partnership with
the UK government and other devolved
administrations on what is sometimes
called a foreign Nations basis
it may be helpful if I take some time
here to set out in brief terms the
resilience system as it exists in
Scotland
in general terms the development of
resilience in Scotland has focused has
focused on consequences not causes
in other words an all risks approach is
adopted
whereby planning can be adapted readily
to fit a wide range of issues
within the Scottish government there are
broadly speaking two functions to
preparedness
the first is a central managerial
function here is Central resilience
division of Scottish government works
with different branches of the
government and public bodies to assess a
whole range of risks whether that be a
risk of flooding or a risk of terrorism
in the case of the assessment of a
pandemic risk There is close cooperation
between the resilience divisions the
Health and Social care Department of
Scottish government and NHS boards
should an incident or emergency arise
Scottish government resilience room can
meet to coordinate and direct actions
designed to respond to the incident
during the covid-19 pandemic the
resilience room met on a regular basis
on a frequent basis and is often chaired
by either the first minister or the
deputy first minister
the second function supports the
development and delivery of the plans
that deal with risks and emergencies
this is underpinned by the Civil
contingencies Act of 2004 of which we
have already heard
that seeks to minimize disruption in the
event of an emergency and to ensure that
the UK is better prepared to deal with
these emergencies
Whenever there is an emergency in
Scotland different organizations work
together to tackle it depending on the
nature of the incident this might
include police Scotland the Scottish
fire and rescue service Health boards or
local authorities
these organations form something called
a resilience partnership which structure
allows them to coordinate collaborate
and to share information
the structure which supports
multi-agency coordination is the
regional resilience partnership there
are three regional resilience
Partnerships in the North in the East
and in the west of Scotland
within each Regional partnership sits
several local resilience Partnerships
the composition of which are determined
by the regional Partnerships
the regional Partnerships and the local
Partnerships bring together all the
relevant organizations in an area to
develop an effective approach in dealing
with emergencies
also supporting the second function the
drill of development and delivery is the
Scottish resilience partnership this is
a core group of the most senior
statutory responders and key resilience
partners
the group acts as a strategic policy
forum for resilience issues
providing Assurance to ministers that
statutory responders and key resilience
partners are aware of any significant
resilience gaps and priorities and that
they are addressing these it provides
advice to the resilience community on
how best to ensure that Scotland is
prepared to respond effectively to Major
emergencies
the Scottish government and statute
responders have long acknowledged and
valued the contribution to National
resilience that is made by the wide
range of bodies in the third sector the
private sector
and Community groups which activate in
response to emergency events
to support Collective discussion around
the all risks approach to preparedness
and response Arrangements the Scottish
government hosts regular meetings of the
voluntary sector resilience partnership
this partnership brings these parties
together to build connections
relationships and an understanding of
each other's capacity and capabilities
to enable better planning and
coordination around emergency response
Arrangements
in this way an assisted by Scottish
government guidance contained in a
series of documents entitled preparing
Scotland
Scottish guidance on resilience which
was published from 2016.
organizations within Scotland are able
to plan for emergency emergency local
and Regional level
this is in fact a simple and easily
understood structure
it was within this structure that
pandemic preparations were made
with mention of pandemic preparation it
may be useful for interested observers
to know a little about the Scottish
government's preparation for a pandemic
the Scottish government's approach to
pandemic planning was Guided by three
things firstly advice from scientists
and experts from the UK and the World
Health Organization
secondly by best practice and thirdly by
prior experience
preparations were again made at a
national regional and local level
some preparations were also made at a
four nations level thus for example the
Scottish government collaborated in the
development of the UK influenza pandemic
preparedness strategy from 2011 of which
we have heard already
this document provided background
information and gave guidance to
organizations for developing plans
further close links existed and continue
to exist between the chief medical
officer for Scotland and the chief
medical officer for the other nations
thereby allowing the exchange of
information on pandemic risk
in addition Scottish officials
participated in a UK government-led
pandemic Readiness flu board
turning to plants meet at a Scottish
national regional and local level the
Scottish risk assessment published in
2018 which we have also heard of
supplements the UK National risk
assessment it identified and analyzed 10
actual risks facing Scotland including
pandemic influenza
which was identified as having a high
likelihood of occurring
the risk assessment provided a means by
which local and Regional organizations
could prepare and respond to the risks
identified
in 2017 the Scottish government
established its own pandemic flu
preparedness board designed to drive
forward particular aspects of pandemic
preparation in Scotland often on default
matters
the Scottish government participated in
a uk-wide pandemic influenza exercise
exercise cygnus in 2016
in 2015 it ran its own scottish-wide
pandemic influenza exercise called
exercise Silver Swan and in 2018 it
exercise Iris assessed NHS Scotland's
response to a suspected outbreak of
Middle Eastern respiratory syndrome
the combined effect of these and other
preparations
was that across Scotland the Scottish
government together with organizations
from Health boards to local authorities
had in place influenza pandemic
preparedness plans
now of course it has to be recognized
that such plans were not an exact match
for a coronavirus pandemic
however many of their features could be
adapted and the Lessons Learned while
preparing for an influenza pandemic were
of great benefit when responding to the
covid-19 pandemic
it should also be recognized that for
much of this period the Scottish
government had to make budgetary
decisions within a climate of austerity
and with many other competing demands on
the public purse from across different
policy areas of government and the
Scottish Parliament further in 2018 and
2019 pandemic preparations had to
compete with preparations for a no deal
for a possible No Deal departure from
the EU for the attention of experienced
resilience and personnel
before leaving this topic I should
mention two measures that helped greatly
with management of the pandemic
the first is the reform of Public Health
structures in April 2020 a series of
reviews co-led by the Scottish
government and the convention of
Scottish local authorities or koslov
culminated in the establishment of
Public Health Scotland and we heard
first thing this morning from Mr Bowie
who represents Public Health Scotland
this unique body brought Under One Roof
responsibility for
the collection of health related data
the thinking to address society's health
issues
and the making of improvements to the
health system
jointly accountable to the Scottish
government and kosler the result was a
single authoritative source of
information and advice
a One-Stop shop if you will that public
and private sector leaders could call
upon this was invaluable during the
covid-19 pandemic
the second measure that I should mention
was a series of protocols for the
management of Public Health incidents
including infectious diseases first
published in 20 in 2003 and updated
thereafter the management of Public
Health incidents guidance on the rules
and responsibilities of nhs-led Incident
Management teams contained information
that NHS boards and local authorities
could use when preparing for order in
response to a public health or
environmental event or incident
these were well-established protocols
that were of great practical benefit
during the pandemic
in summary therefore my lady the
Scottish government has incrementally
built on its pandemic resilience
capability over many years
it is thought carefully about potential
risks and is prepared to the best of its
ability
but of course the devastating effect of
the covid-19 pandemic has shown that
there are many lessons to be learned and
improvements that can be made
the Scottish government has already
taken steps to address this in part
through setting up this of the standing
committee on pandemic preparedness this
is an Advisory Group
bringing together scientists and
Technical experts to advise the Scottish
government preparing for future risks
for from pandemics from pandemics
yet it is not only in the field of
science where improvements can be made
the pandemic revealed in Stark terms
that a healthy and prepared nation is
one where inequalities are not tolerated
the eradication of inequalities in
Health and Social care and the building
of a healthier Scotland has been a
priority for the Scottish government for
several years now
the Christie Commission on the future
delivery of Public Services from 2011
the public bodies joint working Scotland
act from 2014 and the review of Public
Health in Scotland strengthening the
functioning and refocusing action for a
healthier Scotland from 2015 are all
evidence of the Scottish government's
commitment in this area
yet more remains to be done
we would submit that the Candor
displayed in the witness statements
which have been produced to the inquiry
on behalf of the Scottish government are
Testament to the Scottish government's
willingness to listen to learn and to
adapt
Scottish government is grateful to my
lady for the opportunity to make this
opening statement it has been a
necessarily brief and high level
overview of the resilient system in
Scotland
and the pandemic preparation that took
place we hope it has been of assistance
to the inquiry but we also hope that to
those listening and watching the inquiry
process it has provided some insight
into some areas that they may not have
heretofore known about
my team and I hope that we can be of
assistance to my lady and to her team in
the weeks to come thank you
thank you very much indeed uh we'll
break now I shall return at
20 Past 11.
foreign
Mr Sharp good morning milady I'm afraid
I'm hidden from a direct Vision by the
pillar on your left but I can't assure
you um presence into here and we were
going to try and make sure that those
his feet were behind a pillar Mr shop
I'm sorry
um
Beyond unfairness
um would you like to move
um to somewhere where he can perhaps I
could move across yeah
I knew from the outside these pillars
were going to be a problem
right now you need to make sure you've
got a microphone yep
um thank you very much for all of the
assistance offered by my my colleagues
um Milady thank you for this opportunity
to address the inquiry and all those who
have been touched by the tragedy of the
UK covid-19 pandemic
I represent the executive office which I
will also refer to as the Teo one of the
nine government departments
of an Ireland executive which is made up
of five different political parties in a
mandatory coalition
each of the nine departments are
independent and matters only come to the
executive for decision making if they
are significant
to
the remit of the executive office is to
contribute to and oversee the
coordination of executive policies and
programs in order to improve the
economic social and environmental
well-being of the population
stream it Teo has policy responsibility
for civil contingency planning matters
specifically for the coordination of
civil contingencies and emergency
planning
including the wider consequences
big kids
even
the executive
applicable to the Northern Ireland
descent
onto their Direction
functions
in June 2021 the Northern Ireland Civil
Service created a new permanent
secretary role within the Teo to lead
the policy agenda and delivery
Dr Dallas McMahon was appointed as
permanent secretary on 26th of July 2021
I'm ready we will hear from Dr mcmackin
and due course during this module
during the response period the head of
the Civil Service chaired the central
contingency group or ccg the ccg is the
principal strategic civil contingencies
preparedness body for the public sector
in Northern Ireland
the one thing that is important to note
in Melody is that you would have seen
that there were no ministers in
government in Northern Ireland between
the 16th of January 2017 and the 11th of
January 2020.
the executive office performed its
functions during that period within the
Constitutional confines that applied
in this respect my client was acutely
aware of the importance placed by the
inquiry on the question of any impact of
the absence of an executive in that
period
the ministers returned to office on the
11th of January 2020 and the minister of
Health attending the first Cobra meeting
on the 29th of January 2020
Clauses for the inclusion in the
coronavirus act were discussed at the
executive meeting on the 17th of
February 2020.
there was a special ccg covid-19
officials meeting on the 20th of
February 2020 an advice went to
ministers on the 3rd of March 2020
setting out the command control and
Communications or see three Arrangements
that would apply
EU exit Teo has also noted the evidence
provided in terms of EU exit and the
interest of the inquiry in this issue
the EU exit Arrangements including
operation yellowhammer had a number of
very significant impacts on contingency
planning Arrangements across the UK
given the unique circumstances which
applied to Northern Ireland and the
political sensitivities the effects were
more pronounced
austerity the impact of austerity has
also been raised in the evidence to date
this is an important aspect of the
inquiry which can help to set the
contacts for teo's evidence
specifically in terms of reduced
Staffing in the Northern Ireland civil
service and also in terms of wider
Public Service sustainability
the executive office is determined that
the knowledge recommendations and
lessons identified by this inquiry will
be treated with the utmost seriousness
and importance
Teo can guarantee you and those who have
suffered such profound loss that the
department will not be found wanting and
responding to and comprehend
comprehensively addressing changes
recommended by the inquiry
the written evidence from the families
of the bereaved has had a striking
effect upon all who've heard it not
least teo's team
charged with preparing for the
contribution to this hugely important
inquiry
further the module one impact film
demonstrates the depth of loss for
people who were touched by the covid-19
pandemic
it is impossible to view the film and
not be moved
the inquiries rule in highlighting the
prospective and lived experience of the
victims of the pandemic as well as the
experiences of all those involved is
crucial
there is no substitute for this we thank
you and your team to the extent to which
you have conveyed that moving experience
the modular approach as well as the
chair's commitment to produce reports on
each module means that Teo can apply
lessons from those as soon as possible
this means in practice identifying and
learning from the best practice mistakes
and systemic issues that emerge during
the pandemic
demonstrating the importance of good
governance in support of decision making
particularly
when decisions have such a crucial role
in promoting the well-being of the
people who Teo serves
engaging directly with people across all
of society including the equality
grippings to ensure their needs are
incorporated into future plans
and simplifying organizational design
leadership and delivery of high quality
public services for everyone
this week marks the outward commencement
of your investigation military to
understand exactly what happened when it
happened and why it happened the
covid-19 pandemic has had and continues
to have such a profound effect upon
Society in so many ways
those effective must be given truthful
answers to the questions they have asked
since the earliest days in March 2020
those whose lives were irreparably
damaged by the pandemic will rightly
wish to know High future contingency
planning in Northern Ireland can be
designed to avoid any future failures
we share that quest to learn and will
not be afraid to acknowledge will it is
clear the government could have done
better
those are
those are my opening comments and I'm
very grateful for you listening to them
thank you very much indeed Mr Sharp
Mr Strachan sorry about to wait so long
good morning my lady I appear on behalf
of the cabinet office today with Mr
Harland who sits to my right
and my lady d cabinet office would like
to start by expressing its deepest
sympathy to all those who lost loved
ones during the covid-19 pandemic
it acknowledges the huge personal
sacrifices which were made by families
across the country and the dignity and
bravery
of all those who continue to live with
the effects of covid-19
and the cabinet office pays tribute to
the efforts and courage of public
servants and all those who played a role
in the response to the pandemic
from those on the front line of Health
and Social care
to the scientists who worked on the
vaccine and all those
across Society who kept the country
running
the impacts of the pandemic went far
beyond the many whose Health suffered
directly
the virus and the measures taken in
response affected the economy and
Society profoundly
this inquiry will rightly focus on
covid19's profound effect on the United
Kingdom
but it is right to remember that this
was a global pandemic
it affected the lives of everyone
no country was left untouched and each
government had to make extremely
difficult choices in mitigating the
suffering and hardship caused to its
citizens
the UK government established this
independent public inquiry under the
inquiries act 2005 to provide the United
Kingdom with what may be the most
ambitious inquiry into covid-19
undertaken worldwide
and as the former prime minister stated
when announcing the inquiry it is
essential the government's actions its
structures processes and judgments are
examined rigorously candidly
and objectively so every possible lesson
from this terrible Global event as it
affected the United Kingdom is learned
and remembered
to prepare properly free future pandemic
of this kind such reflection and
learning is essential
and it will build on the scrutiny that
the government has received through
parliamentary inquiries and the National
Audit office
my lady the pandemic was the biggest
peacetime crisis our country faced in
decades
its consequences will be felt for
decades to come
but it's important to recognize the many
sacrifices that have been and will
continue to be made across our country
as a result of this virus
and that although the pandemic had
profound consequences for all
its enduring impact on individuals
families communities and groups will
vary significantly
and the cabinet office welcomes the
inquiry's role in considering the
different impacts on all parts of us our
society including those with protected
characteristics under the equality Act
of 2010.
thanks largely to the vaccines covid-19
has now been brought under control
though the pandemic placed huge strain
on our public services and we are still
as individuals and as a society dealing
with the longer term consequences
the government is seeking to address
those consequences for example
supporting those with long covered
including funding research to understand
better its causes symptoms and treatment
and putting in place the elective care
recovery plan to tackle the covid-19
backlog in the NHS
the government's also taking actions to
improve the UK's resilience as set out
in the UK government's resilience
framework
the cabinet office welcomes the role of
the inquiry in investigating the
response of the cabinet office as well
as all other relevant government
departments to this crisis
the inquiry should help us all
understand what went well
and what did not
so as to improve the response should a
pandemic threaten our country again
there will be much to learn from
scrutinizing with the full benefit of
hindsight what happened first in terms
of preparation and then by examining the
response to the breadth and scale of the
crisis created by covid-19 lessons can
and must be learned for a global event
of this kind it will certainly be the
case that things could or should have
been done differently
the cabinet offices overriding aim is to
learn all the lessons it can from such
scrutiny and to make changes where
appropriate to improve this country's
resilience
against such events in the future
both history and science sadly tell us
all of the need to prepare for future
challenges to come
this inquiry offers us the best the the
chance to face them with an open mind
and the best information possible
the cabinet office therefore remains
steadfast in its dedication to
supporting the inquiry in its vital work
in response to the inquiries request for
information in relation to module one
which is Mr Keith has identified concern
the period dating back to 2009 the
cabinet officers provided eight
corporate statements from senior
officials currently working in key
positions in the cabinet office in
addition the cabinets officers supported
nine witnesses to provide module 1
witness statements in their personal
capacities in which they set out their
own views Reflections and suggestions
for improvement in light of the requests
from the inquiry to do so
these include the former Prime Minister
David Cameron cabinet ministers former
heads of the Civil Service
and a number of these witnesses will
assist the inquiry by giving oral
evidence during the forthcoming hearings
the findings of your your inquiry will
enable the country to be better prepared
for any future pandemic
and the cabinet office is Keen to use
its conclusions to build and improve
upon the changes it's already
implemented to enhance crisis management
structures
the cabinet office recognizes that
continuous learning is vital to maintain
effective resilience
the remainder of my opening statement
covers just two main areas
first the role of the cabinet office at
the center of government
as Mr Keith has referred to in his
opening remarks and second a high-level
summary of The Learning of lessons which
the cabinet officers carried out so far
and the actions it is already taking
forward to enhance resilience for the
future
so first if I made just something on the
role of the cabinet office
the cabinet office is a ministerial
Department of his Majesty's government
its ministers currently include among
others the Prime Minister the Deputy
Prime Minister and the chancellor of the
duchy of Lancaster and the minister of
the cabinet office
the cabinet office is responsible for
providing support to the Prime Minister
and the cabinet and to ensure the
government works together to deliver for
the people of the United Kingdom
the cabinet office has a broad and fluid
remit
its key responsibilities in include
supporting Collective government
decision making through the cabinet and
the committee system
as you have heard supporting National
Security and coordinating the
government's response to crises
and promoting efficiency and reform
across government
and monitoring and driving the delivery
of priorities by other departments and
as such the cabinet office has a unique
role in government which shifts in Focus
over time in response to priorities and
challenges as they evolve
within the cabinet Secretariat for
example the cabinet office houses teams
that coordinate policy managed decision
making and look at issues that affect
the whole of government or do not see
sit neatly within any individual
Department
a range of cross-government functions
are based in the cabinet office the
cross-government functions also
comprising multiple agencies and public
bodies support departments and civil
servants across government
to be professional capable and efficient
delivering strong value for money for
taxpayers mitigating and managing risks
to operations and ultimately helping
departments deliver what ministers want
one such function is the government
commercial function which includes the
crown commercial service
the equality Hub was created within the
cabinet office in September 2020 when
the race disparity unit disability unit
and the government equalities office
were brought together
the social Mobility commission
Secretariat joined the equality Hub in
April 2021
and the cabinet office has overall
responsibility for the budget and
resourcing of the equality hub
this is discharged in agreement with the
minister for women and equalities
all of the ministers with equality
responsibilities sit outside the cabinet
office and each has policy
responsibility and decision-making
Authority on their specific equality
issues
and whilst it's grown in recent years
with changes in the Machinery of
government at around seven thousand
full-time equivalent staff the cabinet
office is smaller than some of the
Departments with large-scale delivery
responsibilities
since its work is not orientated towards
tackling one individual issue or risk
its structure and resourcing model adapt
as needed
turning briefly to Cabinet Government in
general the vast majority of decisions
in government are made within individual
departments but some decisions such as
where the subject matter affects
multiple departments need to be made
collectively at cabinet or a cabinet
committee
either at a meeting or through what is
referred to as a right around to a
cabinet
committee
the prime minister of the day with the
advice of the cabinet secretary decides
the overall structure of the cabinet
committee system and there are broad
principles and protocols set down in the
cabinet manual but there's no definitive
list of decisions which must be taken by
Collective Agreement
the cabinet office briefing room or
Cobra committee is the mechanism for
managing the central response to Major
emergencies which have international
national or multi-regional impact and
are of the scale and complexity to
require central government coordination
consistent with its need to provide an
Adaptive response depending on the
emergency there is no fixed membership
of Cobra in general the chair will be
the secretary's state of the government
Department with lead responsibility for
the issue being considered
however with reference to some of the
comments already made about the role of
the lead government department and also
that of flexibility it's also important
to note that invitees will generally
include representatives from those
departments or regions affected by the
crisis under discussion as appropriate
as to the framework for a emergency
preparedness in the United Kingdom
risks are managed by systems in which
departments and organizations from the
public private and voluntary sectors
work together at the local Regional and
National level
the principal role of a cabinet office
with regards to emergency preparedness
is to set and operate the overarching
framework for risk assessment
preparedness response and Recovery
the framework is founded in the Civil
contingencies Act of 2004 to which
reference has already been made and the
inquiry will be considering
this sets out among other things the
role of local resilience forums as a
mechanism for coordinating local
emergency preparedness
and the framework has evolved through
time with Associated regulations and
guidance which is also shaped by other
relevant legislations such as the
equality Act of 2010.
the cabinet office carries out a wide
range of activities aimed at
understanding and enhancing preparedness
for emergencies across the board and
this is underpinned by an assessment
framework encompassing the most serious
National risks facing the United Kingdom
Mr Keith has referred to that part of
the framework which includes the
National Security risk assessment
the published National risk register
and prior to its amalgamation with the
National Security risk assessment in
2019 the national risk assessment
processes
the National Security risk assessment is
the government's main tool
for identifying and assessing the most
serious risks facing the United Kingdom
or its interests overseas over a
multi-year period
as will no doubt be appreciated the
National Security risk assessment cannot
anticipate every possible risk that
might occur across the United Kingdom
but instead brings together groups of
risks of a similar nature in order to
facilitate the planning required to
respond to those risks
the risks included in the National
Security risk assessment are proposed by
lead government departments based on
their own expert internal advice
the National Security risk assessment
process also includes panels of experts
assessing the risks
the assessment is published and is
subject to public scientific scrutiny
it underpins the development of national
resilience planning assumptions
these set out the common consequences of
the National Security risk assessment
risks and these are then shared with
local and National responders to assist
them in their planning to deal with the
major national as well as more localized
emergencies
and the focus on these common
consequences rather than solely on
specific risks is indeed intended to
enable a flexible response to the widest
range of scenarios
this National Security risk assessment
is periodically reviewed
reference has been made to the fact that
specific risks and capabilities that are
identified in the National Security risk
assessment or the national risk
assessments
um are many the way they're managed by
lead departments
they are influenced by the broader
strategic context for that department
such as related policy programs spending
decisions and international factors lead
departments carry out cross-government
coordination chairing meetings as
appropriate as are needed to deliver
their responsibilities
other government departments also
prepare for risks that the National
Security risk assessment process has
flagged up and attend preparation
meetings
my lady the cabinet office does not
audit other government departments in
this sphere
but the cabinet office did carry out
work which was intended to inform other
bodies of their capabilities and to
enhance preparedness planning
this is included work I don't think
referred to as yet
such as resilience capabilities surveys
which were responded to by the local
resilience forums
the resilience capabilities program
which sought to assess how certain work
streams were being prepared for
sector security and resilience plans
which allowed League government
Apartments to set out their approach to
the resilience of their critical
National infrastructure and the national
resilience standards which were intended
to allow local resilience forums and
others to Benchmark their works against
a consensus view of good and leading
practice
where potential impacts are sufficiently
severe or wide-ranging across
departmental responsibilities the
cabinet office May convene and
coordinate across government and that
might include co-chairing official
boards with the lead Department to help
ensure that wider system impacts are
considered
the pattern in intensity by which
cabinet office supports League
departments with their planning for
specific risk varies by risk and through
time and as is typical for the center of
government ministers and Senior
officials will have to decide what level
of support they should provide to other
government departments based on what's
known about the capabilities of that
department
what needs other departments have and
the resources that central government
can commit
the latter is informed by overall
resourcing decisions and the landscape
of emergencies and contingencies that
the government is tackling at any one
time
the cabinet office also has its own role
in leading certain aspects of a response
if one is required for example
organizing cobra
while it can never be optimally
positioned to respond to one individual
risk the cabinet officers channeled
resources to meet specific emerging
needs and over the time period with
which module one is concerned the most
pressing risks at any one time range
from civil contingencies to National
Security threats and wide-ranging policy
and operational challenges
in the period immediately preceding
covid-19 pandemic the dedicated team on
the UK's exit from the European Union
was the biggest single formation in the
cabinet office
in 2020 those resources were reassigned
to covid-19 as the pandemic emerged and
by the end of that year the covid-19
task force had more than 300 people in
it
this task force was wound down in the
spring of 2022 after emerging from the
pandemic and the focus moved on to
Russia's invasion of Ukraine
in terms of devolution the government
works closely with the devolved
administrations to promote effective
emergency planning and response that is
as far as possible aligned across the
United Kingdom whilst respecting
devolved choices
turning to the cabinet officer's role in
pandemic preparedness during the module
one time frame the work undertaken by
the cabinet office in respect of
pandemic preparedness is described in
detail in the witness statements already
provided to the inquiry and as I've
already described the cabinet office
coordinated the risk assessment process
with input from lead government
departments
pandemic influenza was identified as the
top risk throughout the relevant period
new and emerging infectious diseases
were also included in the risk
assessments and registers and throughout
the relevant period Health sector
preparedness was managed by the
Department of Health and Social care
beyond the module one period but noted
here for completeness in July 2021 the
Department of Health and Social care and
the cabinet office jointly established
the pandemic disease capabilities board
to enhance the cross-government across
United Kingdom approach to preparing for
a broader range of pandemics including
but not limited to pandemic influenza
I may turn to Lessons Learned and
actions taken to improve preparedness
I've already noted that the government
set up this inquiry to conduct a
thorough and objective assessment of its
handling of the covid-19 pandemic with
the aim ultimate aim of ensuring that
all of the available lessons are brought
to light so the country is better
prepared when the next pandemic hits
covid-19 developed quickly from an acute
emerging threat to a pandemic requiring
the whole of government to respond to a
chronic challenge
and the cabin office will support the
inquiry to capture every lesson for our
emergency Frameworks and pandemic
preparedness including both where we
need to build on existing strengths or
address weaknesses in the United
Kingdom's response
but the government has sought to learn
and improve throughout the course of the
pandemic in real time the cabinet office
has also commissioned a number of
reviews and made a range of changes to
improve resilience and preparedness more
broadly with further improvements in
train as I'll briefly explain
continuous learning and Improvement are
an inbuilt and vital part of the United
Kingdom's resilience mechanisms
in terms of formal reviews beyond the
crisis whilst respecting the inquiries
process and without prejudice to the
inquiry's own conclusions
the cabinet offices has carried out
formal reviews in respect to resilience
and preparedness including the following
first the Boardman review of cabinet
office Communications procurement which
reported in December 2020 considering
the preliminary results of a
fact-finding exercise into the award of
contracts for covid-19 communication
Services made by the cabinet office in
March 2020 it made three recommendations
in relation to existing procurement
policy and legislation
13 recommendations in relation to
Cabinet office processes and governance
and 12 recommendations into relation to
conflicts of interest and bias and the
government offers sorry the cabinet
office accepted all of these
recommendations
second in January 2021 the Civil
contingencies Secretariat commissioned
the Royal Academy of engineering to
undertake an independent external review
of the National Security risk assessment
methodology
and the Royal Academy of engineering was
asked to address a number of priority
questions focus on scenarios concurrent
and compound risks and interdependencies
assessment time scales and cross-cutting
issues such as data expert input and
diversity and inclusion
it was also asked to deliver
evidence-based practical and
implementable recommendations for
improvement and its report building
resilience was published on the 21st of
April 2023
and the Royal Academy of engineering's
review was conducted alongside an
internal review by the Civil contingency
Secretariat and the Royal Academy of
engineering's review made 13 final
recommendations and the cabinet office
accepted and has or is implementing the
majority of these
thirdly the Boardman review of
government covid-19 procurement which
reported on the 7th of May 2021 covered
five key parts of the government
procurement in response to the pandemic
and identified lessons to be learned for
future procurement and it made 28
recommendations which the government has
accepted an implementation of these has
mostly been completed and has been
subject to review by the government
internal audit agency
4th in June 2021 the National Security
adviser commissioned a review into
crisis capabilities in government which
reported in February 2022 and that
review Drew on Lessons Learned From
recent crises including covid-19 and
aimed to provide an examination of
central government's approach to crises
and that made 23 final recommendations
which of cabinet officers accepted in
full and has implemented them or is in
the process of doing so
the cabinet office has also contributed
to other third-party reviews and
Publications in respect of lessons to be
learned from the pandemic and general
resilience Arrangements including those
conducted or submitted to Parliament
which sit out the side the scope of this
inquiry and more widely the cabinet
office's role is shaped by other
significant government reviews such as
the 2021 integrated review of security
defense development and foreign policy
and that's to you actions to improve
preparedness as a result of these
reviews and Publications as well as
internal lessons exercise exercises the
cabinet office has already made
significant changes to the way
government deals with resilience and
crisis management
amongst other things the crisis
capability review recommended that a new
permanent cabinet office crisis team
should be established
with its responsibilities to include
owning and implementing plans for
scaling up Central government's response
in the face of major crises
and following this the Civil contingency
Secretariat was split into two the Cobra
unit now focuses on the government's
response to emergencies and the
resilience directorate has been
established to lead on longer term
resilience issues
the pandemic exposed the need for a
material Improvement in how government
generates and interrogates data to
support decision making in a crisis
and as a result the national situation
Center
based on the cabinet office was
established and became operational in
October 2021 and it now serves as a
focal point for data and an analysis in
emergencies
Cobra facilities themselves have been
modernized and upgraded including new
physical office space and improved
information and communication technology
provision
and the cabinet office has established
the UK resilience Forum which met for
the first time in July 2021 bringing
together National regional and local
government private and voluntary sectors
and other interested parties
to improve communication and
collaboration on risk and help align
emergency preparedness activity
and in 2022 the cabinet office published
the findings and recommendations from
its review of the Civil contingencies
act and also promulgated a new version
of the National Security risk assessment
and my lady the government published its
new resilience framework on the 19th of
December 2022
and the development and publication of
that was a key commitment made in the
integrated review and it was prepared
following a public consultation with
input from across central government
that evolved administrations local
government the private and third sectors
and of course the public
it sets out the United Kingdom
government's plans to strengthen
resilience to 2030.
and the measures set out in the
resilience framework include first of
all delivering a new resilience UK
resilience Academy built out from the
emergency planningcology with making a
world-class professional training
available to all that need it
secondly the creation of a new head of
resilience position
responsible for guiding best practice
encouraging adherence to best practice
and setting guidance
thirdly introducing an annual statement
to Parliament on civil contingencies
risks and the United Kingdom
government's performance on resilience
fourthly clarifying United Kingdom
government roles and responsibilities
for each National Security risk
assessment risk
thirdly growing the UK government's pool
of advisory groups of experts to inform
risk planning and provide external
challenge
sixthly
strengthening local resilience forums in
England
some building private sector resilience
by providing guidance on risk in order
to help
the businesses to meet new standards on
resilience
eight continuing to deepen and
strengthen the government's
relationships with the voluntary and
Community sector in England so as to
better understand and integrate their
capabilities at the local and National
levels
nine developing a measure for social
vulnerability as an indicator of
socio-economic resilience and how risk
impacts across communities and
vulnerable groups in order to inform
decision making
10 updating Guidance with local
responders
the voluntary and Community sector and
communities to support them working with
vulnerable groups
11. conducting an annual survey of
public perceptions of risk resilience
and preparedness
and 12th establishing a comprehensive
National exercising program focused on
priority National Security risk
assessment risks to test key
capabilities and provide a stronger
framework to capture and track Lessons
Learned identified across government
and alongside the publication of the
resilience framework
the Prime Minister formed a subcommittee
of the National Security Council chaired
by the Deputy Prime Minister to
specifically to consider matters
relating to the United Kingdom's
resilience
the government recognizes there is
always work to be done to ensure that
the United Kingdom is well prepared for
future crises and to this end the
cabinet office will listen carefully to
the evidence and contributions from
other core participants in module one
and looks forward to the inquiries
report and recommendations in due course
thank you very much
Mr strong I gather I Mr
name please forgive me
you're not the first and I fear you may
not be the last so please anybody if I
do mispronounce your name please tell me
I won't be at all offended on the
contrary I'd welcome being corrected so
thank you very much I'll tell my lady I
got used to answering to both I can
imagine yes
right that completes the submissions of
the core participants Mr Keith
well my lady ahead of schedule May I
please call Professor Jimmy Whitworth
and Dr Charlotte Hammer to give evidence
sincerely
and truly
declare and affirm
ation that the evidence I shall give
shall be the truth shall be the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth
I swear by almighty God I swear by
almighty God
that the evidence I shall give shall be
the truth shall be the truth
the whole truth
and nothing but the truth
good morning Professor Whitworth and Dr
Hammer thank you very much for the
preparation of your joint report
as you give evidence could I please ask
you to keep your voices up
it's important that what you say is
recorded and
more important perhaps still than
everybody in the room can can hear what
you have to say
if you don't understand a question
please ask me to repeat it
there will be a break at lunch time
there may be an afternoon break if if
we're still going but if you need
anything or you need a break will you
please let us know
you have prepared a joint report could
we please have it on the screen inq
triple zero one nine six six one one
on page two of that report
you've both signed it
Professor Whitworth on the 5th of June
Dr hammer on the 2nd of June
and you've both confirmed is this right
that the report is your own work the
facts are within your own knowledge
and and do you believe anything else
which relates to your report on which
you have relied and you understand your
duty to this inquiry to provide
independent evidence and
no doubt you will seek to comply with
our duty Milady mayor ask for your
permission for the report to be
published certainly
um Professor Whitworth and Dr Hammer
I'm going to put general questions
they're not directly related to one or
other of you
please decide amongst yourselves
who will answer the question based upon
your Specialties and and what I
understand to be your
consideration in advance of the areas
about which I'm going to ask you
your report
and your own expertise concerns
biosecurity
could one of you please tell the inquiry
in very general terms what biosecurity
is concerned with
um yes I will take that thank you Mr
Case
so in very general terms
biosecurity are those questions that
relate to the biological security safety
of populations individuals and societies
so these are things like
outbreaks so outbreaks of infectious
diseases for example going all the way
to pandemics as we are discussing today
these are also things related to
biological terrorism and biological
warfare
and are you both experts in that field
of biosecurity so the forecasting of
epidemic trends that
the transmission of diseases
particularly zoonotic diseases
biosecurity countermeasures and the like
we are in the report you have set out
for us at page one if we could have page
one of the report please
a short CV of your
your most distinguished histories
setting out your expertise
Professor Whitworth
you are an Emeritus professor at the
London School of hygiene and tropical
medicine
you retired I think in 2022 but you were
the
professor of international Public Health
between 2015 and 2022 is that right
yes
you were chair of the Ethics Committee
you um have a vast experience of working
in the field of biosecurity by with
abroad in the United Kingdom you're a
fellow of the Royal College of
Physicians
The Academy of Medical sciences and the
faculty of Public Health and you also
well you are now president-elect of the
Royal Society of tropical medicine and
hygiene
were you uh at one stage a member of the
World Health Organization European
advisory committee on health research
I was yes may I ask you one or two
questions please in relation to your
work for the World Health Organization
because it finds reflection in a later
part of your report and it's an area
that one of the core participants has
has raised questions about or sought to
ask questions about were you a member of
something called the prioritization
committee
I was yes and what was that a committee
that undertook in 2018
a review of the prioritization of
diseases for what was called the World
Health Organization research and
development blueprint
indeed yes was it essentially concerned
with trying to identify and then
research and develop countermeasures
against
the most highly pathogenic that's
disease-like or
those diseases which are which pose the
greatest concern including coronaviral
diseases
yes indeed that that is looking to
identify those diseases that we're most
worried about from the public health
point of view for which we don't
currently have good tools
and how long did you undertake that work
for for that committee
um since 2015
and did it report
yes um when was that
after each meeting there would be a
report that came out I think the most
recent was 2018.
thank you very much
you've also published over 250
scientific papers and you've provided a
link to a selection of all most recent
articles in the report indeed Dr Hammer
you are the Everett Butterfield research
fellow at Downing College University of
Cambridge
you're based in the department of
veterinary medicine and you're a member
of the steering committee of the of
cambridge's infectious diseases
directorate and you specialize in the
epidemiology of emerging and high
consequence infectious diseases and in
health emergency preparedness and
response
um so essentially your specialty lies in
Global Health security and public health
consequences indeed
and in 2022 of most relevancy were you
um and in fact consultant epidemiologist
to the World Health Organization
covid-19 epidemic intelligence team yes
and you've worked also for another
notable and important International
Network called go on Geo
g-o-a-r-n the global outbreak alert and
response Network
I was a
consultant with them thank you
so in relation to this report you were
instructed in January of this year on
the 20th of January and at Pages three
and four of the report
we can see the the broad areas of
instruction
page three firstly
issues concerning biosecurity threats
priority diseases forecasting and
epidemic intelligence
International processes dealing with
surveillance and the control of
infectious diseases over the page please
and then you turn in your conclusions to
the improvements that you suggest be
made in infectious disease surveillance
to prepare the United Kingdom for future
pandemics
and hot off the press in fact this week
um did the United Kingdom government
publish its biological security strategy
indeed have you been able to review that
and to consider the improvements and
recommendations that the United Kingdom
government itself advances against the
ones that you've suggested in your
report
to some extent since it only came out
this week yes indeed but your report of
course preceded that strategy and its
publication but you've nevertheless been
able to look at it
thank you
could we please turn to page five of the
report and and the commencement of the
substance and
may I ask you what is
a pandemic
so a pandemic in essence is a big
epidemic
um so an outbreak
um of proportions that span the world
are they a new development
pandemics as far as we know have existed
as long as Humanity
and is it self-evident that pandemics
may range in although they are
necessarily worldwide they may range in
um impact in in their scope and severity
indeed
um you've set out in the first few
paragraphs of your report a number of
reasons why we need to be more concerned
about pandemics than perhaps here the
two would be in the case
because you describe
um why the potential for infectious
disease has in recent years greatly
heightened
could you please set out the broad
reasons why you believe that the
potential has heightened
certainly
now
most severe biological threats that we
are facing are transmitted originally
from animals to humans so that's what we
call zoonotic diseases
and the risk for a disease to be
initially transmitted from an animal to
human increases with increasing contact
between humans and animals
particularly if these animals and these
humans did not have contact beforehand
so they did not share pathogens diseases
beforehand
now within more and more interconnected
world we do have more contacts with
animals
we do have movement of people and
animals meaning new animals are
encountering new humans
but we are also impacting what is
happening after a disease has jumped
from an animal to a human that is how
much contact that human has how much
like the likely how high the likelihood
is of that disease then causing wider
spread
so other than two broad areas of concern
one is
we may call it the animal environment
the interface between animals and humans
which gives rise to the risk of a virus
being transmitted into the the human
race and then certainly once
transmission has occurred there is the
concern about
population density migration travel and
trade which encourages greater and wider
transmission absolutely
um can that transmission can the
infection Point occur
at any time or in any place zoonotically
that is to say the the movement or
infection of humans by an animal virus
or are there places in the world where
it's more likely to occur
generally speaking this can happen
wherever an animal has a disease that is
suitable to in fact a human
and then has contact with a human
there are historically speaking some
places where this has occurred more
often
but that does not mean that this is not
possible in other places
a paragraph five of your report towards
the bottom of the page on the screen
you've identified in fact a longer list
of major drivers so microbial adaptation
and change what does that mean
so when we're talking about microbial
adaptation and change that is
broadly speaking which species a microbe
can in fact so that would be the
potential to actually jump to humans
because at the end of the day we are
just one of a whole range of species
and that is also hinting at
antimicrobial resistance which is
another large biosecurity concern and
we'll come back to that in in a moment
ecological changes favoring the
multiplication of a specific
microorganism what is that a reference
to
um so there we are seeing things like
for example changes related to climate
change and also changes related to
things
um that are also mentioned in the in the
further point of land use change so what
kind of environment we have around
ourselves and that impacts blows the
animals as well as the pathogens and in
between those two also vectors so think
about
um insects for example that have a
different range with climate change and
is a vector
does the word Vector mean the means by
which a disease may be transmitted to
human so it could be by way of a flea or
an animal or or indeed even a perhaps a
surface it or Airborne or whatever it
might be there are two meanings to the
work word Vector here
first being
described so where it could also be a
surface so a means of transmission
the second which is what I was more
referring to just now is usually an
insect or a similar
entity in which a pathogen can exist but
it's not infected so it wouldn't be an
animal that is infected but it would be
something like certain species of fleas
it would be something
um
like certain species of mosquitoes that
depends on the pathogen all right
why is climate and climate change of
relevancy
um so as you probably are already seeing
these are all interconnected
and climate and climate change are
driving certain ecological changes and
changes in Vector ranges specifically
further down the page please or over the
page
you've referred to increasing
international travel and commerce
already
then there are direct human inferences
including technology which have impact
upon
Agriculture and land increasing human
population with urbanization
human behavior again you've covered that
immunosuppression in substantial group
of individuals what is the relevancy of
that
a group of individuals who are in
contact with each other who are
particularly susceptible because they
are immunosuppressed we simply have a
higher likelihood of spread
you've referred to the word pathogen or
pathogenic what does that mean so when
we talk about a pathogen we talk we talk
about a microorganism so that could be a
virus
SARS cov2 which is the virus causing
covid-19 that could be a bacterium it
could be a fungus and so these we group
those and together we call them
pathogens all right thank you now it's
also necessary to to set out some other
building blocks concerning the the
fields of biosecurity and
um pathogenic research could we please
have on the screen
zero zero zero two zero seven four five
three
perhaps not oh yes
Professor Whitworth and drama this is a
reference table of previous pandemics
and major epidemics prepared in fact by
the inquiry team I'm sorry that you
haven't been provided I don't believe
with a with a hard copy but but
essentially it sets out
the major pandemics and epidemics
obviously and and a certain amount of
information relating to each and I I
want to just take you through the list
please very briefly in order that we may
begin to understand the names of and
recognize some of the main major
pathogenic threats that we and the world
have faced over time in in order to put
coronavirus SARS Co V2 in its proper
context
so commencing towards the top of the
page you'll see 1918 to 1920 influenza
H1N1
um
we don't I think need to zoom in but
because we're going to look at the table
um as a whole
um that that of course is is what became
known as Spanish Flu is that right
yes
um we can see and the most important
part of it
um the most important information
is towards the right hand side of the
chart where information is provided in
relation to the number of UK deaths and
the case fatality rate as well as the
transmission Route what is the case
fatality rate as you understand it so
the case fatality rate means the
proportion of individuals who who have
become ill who die
and therefore does the case fatality
rate indicate
um the severity
it does of the disease
um influenza H1 known one Spanish Flu
was a respiratory disease is that
correct
further down that the next
entry on the chart is 1957 to 1959
h2n2 we'll come back in a moment to what
the H and the N signify but was that
Asian flu
and on the right hand side of the page
we can see the case fatality rate was
very much lower at
0.017 to 0.1 percent
again a respiratory pathogen
to 70
influenza
H3 9 H3N2
that was known as Hong Kong flu
what does the H
in the
the lettering indicator and what is the
the N IND
uh the H is hemoglutinin and the N is
neuronimidase so they're referring to
different elements of the influenza
virus
I knew you'd know the answer Professor
um
okay does the H or the N indicate in
Broad terms the source of the genetic
makeup of the virus so for example does
H indicate that the virus emanated
originally from a mammal or bird or
something of that sort
in Broad terms yes
but you can't be confident whether it
came from a bird or or a mammal just
from the h and the nomenclature right
then we can see in
um
we can see 1977 to
1978 influenza H1 N1
that was a
influenza that had its possible origins
in China or Russia it became a global
pandemic also called Russian flu
and then
2002 2003
coronavirus SARS Co V1 so SARS plainly
stands for severe acute respiratory
syndrome co-coronavirus
to V coronavirus one this was the first
coronavirus is that correct
a moment or two on SARS cov1
and it commenced in 2002 is that correct
yes
it spread throughout 2003 I think
starting in in Hong Kong
it was notified to the World by an
organization called ProMed about which
we'll hear more later
towards the middle of the page it killed
774 people worldwide
in the United Kingdom there were four
cases and no deaths but the case
fatality rate
was around 9.6 percent
so in terms of the severity
it was very much more severe than the
preceding influenza and other pandemics
to which I've made reference yes
yes
2009 to 10
influenza h191 was that swine flu it was
swine flu struck the United Kingdom
amongst other countries
if we go to the right the middle of the
page Global deaths were assessed have
been assessed at 284 thousand
in the United Kingdom
there were 28 000 odd cases and
tragically
457 deaths but the case fatality rate
was by comparison to Corona's
coronavirus SARS cov1
very much lower at 0.01 to 0.02 percent
is that why
the review into that swine flu pandemic
in the British government's response and
the press and and scientific reports
have generally described that influenza
pandemic as a mild one at least in
Safari's United Kingdom was concerned
yes
Coronavirus
MERS
kovi
is that the Middle Eastern respiratory
syndrome Coronavirus
Global deaths 866 UK cases five UK
deaths three
but the case fatality rate
was very very much higher at
34.3 percent again a respiratory
disease yes
can you say anything about the
difference between that coronavirus MERS
the Middle Eastern respiratory syndrome
and
19.
in terms of whether or not it differed
in terms of whether it was symptomatic
or asymptomatic or whether or not and
whether or not
as a disease there were different
methods of transmission
so for example whether or not it was a
disease transmitted more by aerosol or
droplets from higher respiratory tract
or lower down in the chest
I I believe Professor Haymon will go
into more detail on this tomorrow as
well but generally speaking most is
transmitted quite differently we are
there's there's two main roads so most
is entering the human population
primarily from camel stromadarian camels
so one root of transmission is very
close contact with an infected
dromedarian camel who as far as I
understand it can have mercy
asymptomatically
the other route of transmission which is
the route that the larger merse
outbreaks have gone through is within a
healthcare setting again very close
contact and there you can have either
transmission from Patient to Patient or
from patient to healthcare worker
but the but the degree of human to human
transmission
for MERS was very different to that of
covet 19. yes indeed so although it
could be transmitted human to human it
was only in those very confined
Healthcare settings that it actually
took place
and then Ebola at 2013-16
of a
so far the highest case fatality rate
62.9 percent
but it's not a epidemic or pandemic that
has
Afflicted the United Kingdom there have
been three cases and no deaths
and then finally down to coronavirus
SARS cov2
our covid 19.
and to put that terrible disease in its
context we can see in the middle of the
page Global deaths range
from an upper figure of 30.6 million to
a lower figure of 6.9 million of course
there
was there are ways of measuring deaths
and in the United Kingdom
more than 90 percent of the population
is assessed to have been infected to by
the disease to have caught it and they
have official figures recount being 225
668 deaths
the infection fatality rate is something
different to the case fatality rate is
it not it is yes what is the difference
so the case fatality raid takes the
proportion of cases so people who have
become ill whereas the infection
fatality fatality rate takes the
proportion of infected people including
those asymptomatically infected
so essentially case fatality rates rest
upon a confirmed case of infection there
has to be an identified case whereas an
infection fatality rate is an assessment
based on those who have become infected
whether or not that has been confirmed
in some way or not
yes and no of course I think I'm going
to need you to run me past this run it
past me again
I'll I'll try my best to do that
um so with a case fatality rate we
usually specify what cases we mean do we
mean
only confirmed cases if so confirmed how
laboratory confirmed or confirmed by a
clinician or do we also include for
example probable cases or suspected
cases
with the infection fatality fatality
rate this becomes a little more
complicated because it is very difficult
to assess the extent of infection
especially with diseases that can occur
asymptomatically
which also means that in many cases our
confidence in the infection fatality
rate is lower than in the case fatality
rate because there is a certain amount
of estimation of the total number of
infections
right so
standing back and looking at that child
in 2019
SARS cov2 was therefore the third
coronavirus pandemic
but the second
Souls
pandemic there had been one
SARS pandemic the coronavirus SARS cov1
in 2002 and then the coronavirus MERS
pandemic or epidemic in 2012 and
therefore covid-19 the third in 2019
. our coronaviruses common in in animals
such as bats and Civic cats and camels
and so on
indeed they are are there hundreds
if not thousands if not thousands but
not all of them in fact humans
no
do a significant proportion
there's
um I think four uh endemic
coronaviruses that affect humans and
they cause mild common cold symptoms and
then there are these three more recently
experienced coronaviruses that have
caused epidemics in the human population
so of these thousands of coronaviruses
there have been just seven that we're
aware of that affect humans and what
does endemic mean to which you referred
endemic means that it is constantly
within the human population
does the fact that there have been three
coronavirus pandemics in relatively
short order in this century
indicate anything at all
that is a very good question I'm very
glad to hear that
certainty
now
certainly it does point to the issues we
covered before in terms of increasing
human animal interfaces
but beyond that it's probably very
difficult to say anything
and indeed what we haven't covered what
is on the top of this page but going
further back even we can't with
certainty say how many coronavirus
pandemics there have been throughout
history
could we then put that chart aside
please and return to your report at
on page five
foreign
as you might expect professor and doctor
the United Kingdom government as with
many other governments has long
acknowledged the the risk posed by
biological or zoonotic diseases and
disease generally and
the international nature of biological
threats has long been classified as a
what is called a tier one risk
by the United Kingdom government
is it obvious that therefore such risks
have long been part of the United
Kingdom's preparedness planning
I would assume so
all right
you turn further down the page to the
three broad categories of biosecurity
threat that we currently face
and at paragraph four you set them out
as being in three categories zoonotic
spillover
antimicrobial resistance and human
origin biosecurity risks
zoonotic spillover you've already
described as being a leak if you like or
a transmission between animal and human
over the zoonotic interface but but what
is antimicrobial resistance
so antimicrobial resistance is a natural
phenomenon of
microorganisms so for example bacteria
viruses adapting to broadly speaking the
environment
and that environment for these
microorganisms
includes drugs we use on them so things
like antibiotics
so that then means that those
microorganisms adapt and learn how to
deal with those drugs which brings
considerable harm as it means that
things which we thought we could treat
become less treatable even untreatable
and also because large parts of modern
medicine particularly surgery we rely on
us being able to
um control bacterial risks
the third category
the deliberate
security risks is self-evident and we'll
come back to the detail of that in a
moment so with those three categories
broadly in mind can we just focus please
for a moment on zoonotic spillover
can
does zoonotic spillover present a
a range of risks or effects
can it be that following a zoonotic
spillover that there may be limited or
no risk for the human race
as the evidence show that it has had
potential pandemic
impact yes
is there anything that can be said about
the degree of risk so for example
chart of impact or towards the upper end
so the pandemic end we see the whole
range and even within individual
pathogens
if we take for an example stepping back
from coronaviruses if we take Ebola as
an example
we see a quite a number of spillovers of
Ebola where we have a handful of cases
and then we also see large outbreaks
like the one referenced in the table the
2013 to 2016 outbreak in West Africa or
the more recent 2018 to 2020 outbreak in
the Democratic Republic of the Congo so
there we see with the even within one
pathogen we have consider considerable
variants
and can such zoonotic spillovers be
viruses or coronaviruses or
well there can be viruses they can also
be bacteria so this is not just viruses
if we take for example the plague some
of you may know that as the Black Death
from the Middle Ages that is a zoonotic
organism as well
um so I think most of us will probably
know the stories from the Middle Ages uh
plague coming from rats with a flea in
between probably so there you see
another example of a zoonotic pathogen
this time of bacterium
Mr Case forget my interrupting I think
you've been pushing your luck with our
very patient stenographer so would you
like to choose a moment but that's an
ideal moment my lady
thank you
all very much professor and Dr Howard um
will return at quarter to
please
thank you I'm may we please have the
reference table of previous pandemics
back up on the screen
inq30 is two zero seven four five three
please
professor and doctor I wanted to return
to an issue that we explored this
morning and just ask you one or two
further questions on it please
are the number of deaths caused
in any pandemic
the result of differences in both
transmission of a disease and the
severity of the disease
they certainly are they are also a
result of changes in overall population
across the planet
but once a disease infects the human
race and let's assume it spreads
the number of deaths will be determined
by how transmissible
diseases and how severe the disease is
yes
so on the one hand you may have a
disease that doesn't transmit very well
but if you get it
you are in very deep trouble indeed
or you may have a disease that transmits
extremely easily but is less dangerous
less severe and therefore less likely to
kill you and therefore
there's a better Prospect you'll survive
indeed so MERS for example 2012
as you were
saying earlier
if we could just highlight thank you
very much
MERS
was a virus
I think
originally from from local bats but the
reservoir the the
um the carrier of the virus was camels
and camels could then infect humans
there weren't very many cases worldwide
and there were certainly very few cases
in the United Kingdom and three deaths
but
chains of infection
that is to say the way in which
people infected other people tended to
die out after a few cases and you could
only get MERS couldn't you from
very limited
scenarios
for example a healthcare worker treating
somebody who was infected with MERS and
was capable therefore of infecting the
healthcare worker yes
so that was known as stuttering
transmission the transmission didn't
flow easily there wasn't widespread
human to human transmission
and therefore the the overall numbers
were relatively speaking very very low
although course each death is a is a
terrible tragedy but there was no
widespread transmission but if you
happen to get MERS
the fatality rate whether judged by the
number of overall cases or judged by the
number of
unconfirmed infections
was very high indeed is that the
position yes yes whereas by contrast
swine flu
2009 influenza h191
had a very much lower case fatality rate
and although it tended to spread more
easily it was a flu
it was an influenza pandemic
it had a very much lower case fatality
rate doesn't really matter whether it's
a case fatality rate or an infection
fatality rate
if you became infected with it there was
a very very very much greater chance
that you would survive correct correct
so the disease to avoid is a disease
that is both transmissible and severe
indeed
and that of course is a disease that
must be prepared for
Malay dad I it balances the progression
that you pose thank you
please inq000
and
[Music]
describing your report
how there are coronaviruses and we've
heard
which have been of the greatest concern
and and you discuss influenza but you
refer in paragraph eight to
disease X isn't a real disease as you
say it's a hypothetical scenario
what is the benefit
countermeasures or preparedness of
basically the idea behind diseasex is
that it is not unreasonable that we will
encounter a
disease that we did not previously know
the properties of
obviously preparing for something that
we do not know the property
critical disease
that we don't know the properties of
just like we might not know the
properties of a
face X is supposed to teach us
how to prepare for unexpected things and
how not
has this approach of trying to identify
or or focus on a hypothetical disease
being a more recent development
um
the idea of preparedness inherently has
an under
and a half and by that do you mean
scientific bodies based United Kingdom
and abroad and the World Health
Organization in particular has focused
focus on how best to take steps to
prevent against what that disease may
turn out to be
um
membership of the committee in in in a
sense was that committee by prioritizing
attention on particular diseases
including coronaviral diseases trying to
identify
see
yes that would that would be true if we
think about coronaviruses we know there
are many thousands of those
we had had experience of two Corona
into the human population during the
21st century and it was a reasonable bet
that another one might come into the
human population
with covid here and it's also very
plausible that another one might come
along in the future
to me what is the Practical benefit to
us all of focusing on disease X
obviously the the precise
I think twofold I think one it
it encourages us to be to be flexible in
in our approach and not to
very slavishly think about what we did
also it allows us to develop a sort of
generic framework of how we would deal
with a disease that were spread say by
the respiratory route was of a certain
measures we would need to put in place
to be able to control such a disease
professor
the United Kingdom
kovid 19.
focused its attentions on a influenza
pandemic
but was struck of course by Coronavirus
so from the Viewpoint of
December 2019 that coronavirus curvy 19
was the disease X it was
therefore that they did
over slavishly focus on influenza and
not what the other disease
I think that's a fair criticism
the biological properties of this
disease and so at that
more information it would be best to to
start
that we need to be flexible to change
that as the evidence emerged
quite so but much of what you've said of
course is concerned with being
struck us
do you believe that there was too great
a focus
not exclusively a focused but too great
I think that's a fair criticism
with the two coronavirus
epidemics that
urgents in the epidemiological features
of that the transmissibility and the
severity and the amount of symptomatic
versus non-symptomatic cases that were
there which means that it would be
symptomatic
um certain viral infection means
um uh if one thinks about
might show symptoms and have disease or
they might
view even if you were to focus on an
influenza pandemic exclusion of all
other pandemics you would necessarily
have to prepare for both asymptomatic
and symptomatic versions of that
pandemic indeed yes but bringing you
back to the debate about disease X
if in the scientific community
for some time now there was a an
appreciation of the importance of
focusing on the hypothetical disease X
to make sure that you weren't blindsided
disease
but why then
um why then was that
in dealing with influenza uh epidemics
that occurred previously and
um to use that as a starting point of
how you would approach uh
and into that
mixture what about the fact that they
had
that's true that really ought to be
factored in as well but remember that
those two were quite Divergent in their
effects
virus this is the plan we need to follow
thank you well that's that's very clear
large your major categories of
um of risk anti-microbial resistance
of your report
I want to ask you please a
Little Resistance you refer there to the
fact that
has two features to it
um there is the first firstly the issue
of transmissibility that is to say
if you have a disease a pathogen that
can't be controlled
by for example antibiotics then there is
the concern that the particular disease
or pathogen could spread easily
transmissibility and also that there is
the
pathogens what is that second reference
mean
s between pathogens
um so this is a specific feature
particularly of of bacteria that develop
resistance
and between themselves by the way of how
a bacterium Works biologically
can be shared between bacteria
and therefore that has an impact upon
the
line
of the disease and of the spread of
resistance in general so it's a
cascading effect indeed all right
the the
last year in paragraph 16 you refer to
the fact that Ami antimicrobial
resistance has gained the label silent
pandemic
you make the point that the precise
future course of antimicrobial
resistance is uncertain
but is the point that
consequences from AMR as well yes
has that risk changed over the last few
years
awareness increase what we call
antimicrobial stewardship so trying to
slow down the spread of
of resistance so I would not want to
speculate what that would mean for that
estimated number all right
the third broad area of biosecurity
threat that you identify is what you
page 11.
commences at page 10 I'm sorry page 10
paragraph 18.
um
and you describe how there is a non-zero
risk
human behavior
and have there in the recent past
been any
if we look at accidents first these have
happened in the past
um so we are aware of four incidents
involving the first
um the 2007 foot and mouth disease
outbreak in the UK which some of you
might still remember that was a
laboratory leak um that was an
accidental
just one that we are aware of was in
2019 and that was a brucella outbreak in
China again associated with
whether or not a disease
uh infects the the human race by virtue
of a laboratory Act
does that matter
um in in terms of
thoughts from a zoonotics build over or
an accident or malicious use the fact is
that the transmission has stopped
Dynamic it probably does not matter at
all anymore where the first very first
case came from at least in terms of
addressing that particular pandemic
I'm trying to stop these outbreaks from
happening at all
but in terms of the preparedness and
response for if it happens
obviously if we talk about things like
um altered pathogens there might be
slight changes but then again that would
probably fall on
trying to leave there may be some
purpose to be gained in identifying
one of these three broad biosecurity
threats as being human origin
Behavior a leak or deliberate use in
terms of focusing on
well I think the importance of knowing
where something came from is
predominantly in finding out if this is
an Avenue that we can shut down for the
future so is this for example on the
naturally occurring side is this a
common interaction between humans and
animals which can be made safer
on the laboratory
yes and then obviously when we talk
about malicious use there are other
forensic and security implications all
right
now
um a government in any country when
faced with
a with a number of conundras or not that
there are all number of considerations
which have to be taken into account when
deciding how to react and you you set
some out of paragraph 22 on page 11 of
your report
another one
through the considerations which you've
set out there because they all have an
impact on how any government will
respond
a small cluster of infections has
variable potential to become widely
established in the population and this
is challenging to predict accurately in
advance is that a way of saying that
when any outbreak starts you just don't
know whether it's going to become an
epidemic or a pandemic or how wide it'll
go
whether it's a problem or whether it can
be ignored
so initially with an initial cluster you
might not know and the response will
then vary a
found a local team investigating that
outbreak
um and if possible trying to control and
shut it down
and then obviously if that does if that
fails you kind of
um determining if something requires you
to as you put it push that red red
button
and if you the more surveillance you
carry out and the more
yourself as a government to knowing
what's going on in the rest of the world
and
and how many outbreaks are are occurring
presumably the greater the risk or the
greater proportion of those will be
false alarms the more
the more false alarms there will have
been so that adds an additional
they can't follow every possible alert
and every time they cry wolf everybody
else's sense of preparedness will
diminish
why then is surveillance important
um you go on to describe in in detail
the various different ways
secondly all fully to every single alert
but why does knowing that there are more
and more alerts out there help us
alert the earlier you're alert
the more likely you can actually respond
to it because the response will be much
more
say routine investigation into a case or
a cluster of cases and it will also
require a different
talking about early response here we're
not talking about the response as we've
seen over the past couple of years we're
talking about a small local team
investigating
to find out what has happened and if
there is
but it doesn't become a crisis indeed
and in fact
that or any sense of any system of
global surveillance and local response
to prevent um I don't know a drama
becoming a crisis
requires therefore visibility or
transparency around the world because we
all have to know therefore what's going
on in some other part of the world where
outbreaks
mean when you refer
so
ensuring that
they are well funded that they
can that so one Health is specifically
collaborative multi-sectoral
transdisciplinary approaches across
humans animals and the environment so it
is the working
T threats that we've outlined zoonotic
diseases and antimicrobial resistance
both of those happen at the intersection
between humans animals and the
environment
and for example if you think
it is not unreasonable to think that you
might see something in the animals first
but if the animal health sector and the
human health
possible to have those early alerts even
potentially before we see first human
cases
and if if I made yes
because you wouldn't see that much wider
picture of the interaction in the
environment and with other
it is about trying to understand more
broadly and
becoming agreed or Worse yes indeed you
describe
in the context of savants a number of
different methods of surveillance and
alert systems you you describe something
called syntromic surveillance and
Horizons
are there a number of international and
alert systems and are there a number of
different ways of carrying out surveyors
19. the
United Kingdom and and the
round about the same time they became
informed from doctors in China
uh they became
and the who China office also issued an
alert this was all at the end of
December 2019.
system
is there a need for more surveying
systems or multiple surveillance systems
and if there is an international
surveyance system does the United
Kingdom have to have its own surveyance
system ultimately
the United Kingdom was with the rest of
the world informed at the end of
December 2019 that there was an outbreak
International surveillance
at least if we're talking about
traditional surveillance say not looking
at media alerts
we only need one or we only need the
other
um
for pandemic preparedness and response
convened in 2000
.
um it's not something I confess that
you've addressed in your
relates to some of the matters that
you've covered
from the Independent panel
pandemic preparedness and response
indeed um is that something that you're
able to to discuss I don't know doctor
whether you've you happen to have a copy
there yes
or pandemic preparedness and response in
very small letters covid-19 make it the
last pandemic could we just go forward
slowly a couple of pages at a time
and we'll get our bearings
so they're the
made by the panel after review of the
devastating reality of the covid-19
pandemic
could you please go to page 15 of what I
hope 86 pages
[Applause]
honestly and it says this in under three
months from when SARS cov2 was first
identified as the cause of clusters of
unusual pneumonia cases in Wuhan
covid-19 had become a global pandemic
threatening every country although
Public Health
National commissions and reviews had
warned of potential pandemics covid-19
still took large parts of the world by
surprise
has been accelerating many of which of
pandemic potential
ignored warnings and the panel refer to
the SARS epidemic about which you've
spoken in in
2003 and then further later down the
page where we didn't go to it to Mars
and Ebola
now
that that
view which you may or may not share
would would tend to suggest that
prior existence or the prior occurrence
of
SARS Cove
should have put the world generally
into a greater stage of preparedness
that in that very
Not Crying Wolf not being over prepared
for something that doesn't come and
being properly prepared for something
that that does come
there should have been a just a higher
degree of awareness
the possibility that the next pandemic
would be a coronavirus would you agree
with
by the medal of of January of 2020
people
was going to die away this looked like
it was it was something bigger than that
and I think by the end of January
an impending wave that was was coming to
the UK and those of us who had
Kingdom but countries in the Far East
yes and and that gives rise doesn't it
to the debate about their preparedness
because they had been through SARS
55.
the
the panel in the different
an approach to responding to pandemics
by applying what's known as the
precautionary principle
transmission and therefore be more
transmissible
um
said this at the bottom of the page
early dissemination of the outbreak
alert countries around
the level of risk was based on its
established principles Guided by the
international Health regulations
while the who advise on the possibility
of human human Transmission in the
period until it was confirmed and
recommended
the panel's view is that it could also
have told countries that they should
take the precaution
so what the paddle appeared to be saying
assume the worst assume it will be human
to human transmission
and therefore prepare for that for that
one
requires a response at all
what do you say about the notion or the
the argument that there should be
you should assume that the next
significant outbreak will be human to
human trans will have significant human
I think there's a fine balance
um
the clusters of of cases which might or
might not
daily basis to take the precautionary
Viewpoint that each one of those could
turn into a pandemic would be a huge
waste of of effort and resources
to
sift and we can identify those that we
are worried about until they reach a
certain stage I think is a sensible
approach once they reach a stage that
yes this is something we are worried
about
required but that will be for a very
small minority of all the outbreaks
two senior members of UK Public Health
Community in late January they were of
the view that they
ought to overreact rather than under
react to this
the outbreaks occurring and then you can
assess and sift but then there would be
something to be said for applying a
precautionary
organization identified what's known as
a
pheic on the 30th of January 2020 a
public health emergency or Internet
International concern
so
pandemic it wasn't declared a pandemic
until March
is there however something to be said or
would something be
missionary principle at that stage when
the world began to realize there was a
outbreak serious enough to call it a
public health emergency of international
concern
and say well let's assume from then on
case in hindsight yes
I I would agree with that
um but again if you
concern or who
then that has
outbreaks pathogenic outbreaks disease
outbreaks that are declared a public
health emergency of international
concern by the
presume human human transmission for
every outbreak you should only do so in
relation to those that are serious or
significant or which have the real
capacity to cause damage
there aren't that many diseases that are
declared at pH
so it is a very small number and one of
the critiques of that system is that
it's a
it either is a public health emergency
of international concern or it isn't and
to have a more nuanced yeah great
would be beneficial
right and maybe also often note here for
something to be a public health
emergency
but can very well be a public health
emergency of international concern
now well whilst we're looking at
a structure called the international
Health regulations which in 2005 which
which underpins the who's approach to
just for historical interest and
primarily is it is there a a process of
individual country's response
under the
Health regulations
there is and it is that what
um how did the United Kingdom fare in
those International based but locally
assessed
before the covert pandemic
UK has never undergone to our knowledge
of formal joint external evaluation it
and scored highly and it has
participated in self-scoring
as a joint external evaluation which
again it has done
what's known as the global Health
security index
yes that that was also done I believe
by who
and again it did
relatively well in in that assessment as
well it did
well the United Kingdom has fared in any
I'm not aware
well of any since
not after so
and in that the UK did fairly well with
a 93 score
so that's 93 yeah
scores
um can we then turn please to page 13 of
your report paragraph 26.
the issue of response capacity with
scale up capacity
uh and you make the point which we we
may
which which made some
it's critical that there is sufficient
capacity to respond
refer to a metric or a standard a target
of a certain number of epidemiology
epidemic
population and as being a standard or a
metric proposed
for
um
could you just explain
or the same amount of epidemiologists
might have made a difference in
those days of the end of December 2000
to a moment ago these would be primarily
staffed by field epidemiologists so
having those being able to address
things in early stages makes a
significant difference but also
obviously these people then
a lot of intervention strategies in
terms of the epidemiological side so
that
would be either being able to run
dedicated new surveillance systems even
being able to come up with a dedicated
the context of the United Kingdom and I
appreciate this is a huge huge area
um can you say
as sufficiently blessed with the right
number of epidemiologists
search base that is required in
responding to any outbreak or pandemic
mechanisms diagnostic testing vaccines
clinical care and so on and so forth
um so
response to outbreaks the international
standard is one trained field
epidemiologist per 200 000. this is a
scaled down version of the US Target of
one per 100
000.
how many field epidemiologists there are
there are some proxy measures that
aren't particularly perfect either
um
other things that you mentioned though
things like clinical capacity things
like developing testing they require us
really large capacity
you address in paragraph 29 on page 14
that
the social scientists clinicians Animal
Health experts and so on and so forth
again relatively self-evident what one
might think
um can you express a view as to whether
or not generally across
resource and the clinical and the
microbiological and the
um
I'd say that generally yes we were but I
think the point about
so good at I think we had these various
groups and these various pools but they
were not necessarily interconnected
in much greater detail later
um
could you now forward please to page 17.
what are you doing Mr Keith could I just
go it's going back a bit I just wanted
to check
accurately noted what she said and then
check whether you Dr Hannah agree and
what I've noted
point until we gathered more data is
that an accurate
record of what you said yes my lady and
Dr Hammer do you agree
so first of all
any plan for a respiratory outbreak will
be better than none
then one for something else
but I think
thank you very much
um so page
17 please thank you
of your report
um
High consequence infectious diseases
which are on
the advisory committee on dangerous
pathogens
relation to which the United Kingdom
vaccines Network
uh
invests in vaccine development as a
priority and then you actually go on to
deal with other lists of pathogens kept
by other International bodies and by
overseas bodies for example the National
Institute of allergy and infectious
diseases in the United States of America
that was thought to be flexible that
coped with the possibility of a generic
pandemic we didn't as a country proceed
by way of trying to identify every
possible significant risk and then
planning for it
specifically to identify what are the
priority diseases for which the world
needs vaccines
four will put out a a call for work to
be done to develop vaccines or whatever
for a specific disease
missions the same sort of thing with the
UK vaccines Network
um that had
right for a country to be thinking about
what the risks are and how one
um deals with
new and emerging infections that are
coming up but the follow-through for
that is that one ought to have a plan
that is a framework for how you would
deal with a respiratory
disease or
um and if that's the case that's fine
not to have a list as such but you've
got a framework for how you would deal
with categories of disease
sensible one is is not to operate on the
basis of a
a
prescriptive list of priority diseases
this is how we'll prepare for that
disease this is how we'll prepare for
this
the various
died by the United Kingdom there was a
general preparation
although they were overlaps for what was
called a new and emerging infectious
disease
the precise nature of which wouldn't
yes I think it I think it is sensible
it allows one to be flexible in in one's
produced for the high consequence in
Infinity on dangerous pathogens
considers we've got a a list there that
we ought to have plans
contact transmission how one would deal
with respiratory transmission uh so so
in fact what you're suggesting is that
there should
framework to deal with
the unexpected outcome the disease or
the pathogen that takes us by surprise
yes indeed all right
you then deal with expert advisory
groups in the United Kingdom
Advisory Group nerve tag about which
lady we will hear a very great deal more
in in module two
evidence group has the advisory
committee on dangerous pathogens to
which you've just mentioned
acdp which you just mentioned and also
the national expert panel on new and
emerging infections
might it be thought that we have
rather
um
committees and groups in the United
Kingdom dealing with various assets
infections dangerous pathogens new and
emerging infections and the like is
there an argument for some
rationalization of those bodies
I think it is useful as expert groups to
have them focused on the areas where
I think they do have robust discussions
and Divergent
expertise to do that I think what is
real
to get an overarching view of the risks
and and is that because
by their very name
slightly different area so
nerve tag only considers respiratory
viruses because it is the new animal
I mentioned the national expert panel on
unemerging infectious diseases which I'm
sure
um did exactly
how it described itself on the tin has
in fact been disbanded
yes it has
um the the next area in in your report
is the area of forecasting modeling
Horizon scanning and
epidemic intelligence I didn't think
professor and Doctor the the
will will be assisted by description of
the differences between forecasting more
ladies is that a suitable point for a
break yes of course sorry I've done no I
was slightly taking both spots now
um I shall return at 5
.
thank you
foreign
pleased to publish the written opening
statements you may
um
you about a particular type of epidemic
intelligence Pro-Med the program for
monitoring emerging diseases
Jesus so a a group of
scientists and it's been going for
um about 30 years now and it's an
internet service
events occurring around the world and
there's a network of people who report
these
um
24 hours a day every day of the week and
so on and that information is then
shared globally and uh
I mean they're focusing on social media
chatter or Health Department
announcements or stories from small
media Outlets
that's part of it yes many of them are
health professionals who will have heard
through the course of their work that
there's a few cases of what apparently
are related conditions occurring
somewhere in the country and will an
alert be issued
does the system work on the basis that
there must be some
it's moderated and edited but a single
report is is sufficient to be posted and
what was the role of
David and alerting the world to the
outbreak in China
um
first report
pneumonias of Unknown Origin
and so is is Pro-Med uh
a
Source
um that ought to be protected or perhaps
better funded or
nurtured
very valuable role I have no insight
into how robust it's
funding
but I think
as well
similar
reporting networks and these are
increasingly being coordinated and
brought together
89 paragraph 76.
um I
the the United Kingdom formally left
the institutions and structures of of
the European Union was
control
yes sorry I did not hear the question
mark at the end of that sentence
about the ecdc what does it do on the
European
frame
um yes so the ecdc is an EU membership
and an EU agency
some other countries for example Norway
is also a member and it has a key role
in
the European Union primarily the
European Union
um
quite important to to note here that
obviously there's quite a difference
between what is needed
Nation States where there's in an
individual nation state so easy
additional need in a union of state so
there's
um that is with regard to coordinating
cross-borders
coordinating capacity building across
borders and similar cross-border issues
but the need for such across
is mitigated to a very
when I mentioned it beforehand that
National and international are running
in parallel and informed by each other
different degree also applies to other
countries that are working together and
for example for that we also have the
who region
of the who European region so there's
another
Bronson response capacity and so on
um in practice
if not in
ability for the United Kingdom to to
take any benefit from the European
Union's early warning and response
system if it wished to do so
I believe so I do not know the specific
legal context for that but I
wanted to additional countries
um by the European commission and that
goes by decision of the European
commission and examples of that are
has its own fully fledged substantive
and comprehensive system for for doing
all the things that it
Union
um is um you talk at paragraphs
uh the United Kingdom's approach in the
form of Public Health England
has now been subsumed into the United
Kingdom Health Security Agency was seen
internationally as something of a beacon
in the area of Public Health
approach to
this particular area of Public Health
are on the on the United Kingdom
approach
indeed there are examples where that has
happened what what public health England
did was it
various aspects of Public Health under
the one body so control of infectious
diseases but also control
under the one body
was was the strategy that they used in
public health England and that had
is modeled on that public health England
model and I was um recently in
all that has been followed in other
places
the public health England or public
health England has now been
the United Kingdom Health Security
Agency and Regional Health authorities
and in part the Department of Health and
and social care indeed
and emulated have we gone in and now in
a different direction to that which we
had before we have gone in a different
direction now
in public health England does that
matter
um
I think it's a question of preference my
personal opinion
is beneficial and that there are
cross-learning
communicable non-communicable control
together and having your health
an issue that we'll be looking at in the
context of
dhsc Witnesses and due course at
paragraph 83
infectious diseases is in flux as change
it are there significant changes
underfoot do they matter
um so
are you so far is quite more substantial
than the ihr were
um so there's
now a first draft being discussed
um that is with members
very very early days
um so it is very difficult to say
anything yet because it can be expected
that there will still be changes made to
that draft that discussions will still
decided today or even a week ago it will
take time for us to see what the impact
of that will be this is not something
that is
[Music]
have to evaluate a little bit down the
line are you able to say anything about
International Health regulations for
example will it provide for very real
differences in terms of
of infection or an outbreak I mean how
far beyond the current regulatory regime
is the treaty likely to go
highly depend on what the member states
of the
um of the assembly actually are able to
agree on
so
there's no smoke that tells
distance with the likely time frame for
any such treatment all right
well in light of all that uh
dependent panel for pandemic
preparedness response to which I
referred which I referred you to earlier
and we can see the main point set
Focus independent who
investment in epidemic preparedness now
stronger accountability
spare action improve system for
surveillance and alert platform for
vaccines Diagnostics
preparedness and response
those are all laudable aims but pitched
at if
level of generality they're they're very
Broad
have you given thought to
what sort of of more perhaps more
precise recommendations
um have been suggested by the scientific
community
recommendation should in your joint
opinion
um be made
and are they at paragraph 87
page 32
uh yes thank you
um so we we've listed here a number
one is that having uh sufficient Reserve
capacity within the
of the health system we heard this
morning from representative from the
cabinet's office talking about
resilience there
in process but we don't know and we feel
this is in
for diseases that needs specific staff
and if that pulls them away from their
other conditions that aren't part of
that
outbreak that is there so in terms of
resilience
you create that additional capacity
particularly in the laboratory and and
just pausing there resilience as we've
heard is is is about a I suppose a
standing capacity of a country to be
able to absorb and knock to to be able
to
to respond to
to roll with the blows and and to
recover
so having extra capacity in terms of
improving your resilience is something
more
than being able
bent requires it it requires more
that's right I I think generally there
are two approaches to resilience one is
that there's a degree of redundancy in
the system so that there are sufficient
staff who can be deployed to a specific
area and the other is that you have
staff that are
trained in
different
interesting to the requirements of the
system all right and and you've you've
referred there to obviously to a a b
and how Healthcare Providers and public
health teams can work alongside
Community leaders
in the world of of biosecurity
that is again a self-evident and audible
lame
how will that bring about practical
benefit
that the impacts were not felt
this
bad and I believe the inquiry is hearing
evidence on Friday on this matter as
well so clearly there is a recognition
that this is an important issue not so
much in preventing a
to the need to ensure scientific
advisors are not only independent but
autonomous
um that that may be
well in in module two
why is
Independence and transparency of
that brings about quantifiable benefit
think in terms of the Independence that
um
enhances transparency and to gain
Community Trust
gave advice and so on I think I think
that's very valuable
autonomy the issue there is that
experts aren't simply responding
diversity of import
guards against group think
fit of developing the recommendations
for future epidemics
refer to the need for inaction and after
Action reviews
number of reviews since the covered
pandemic by Parliament by parliamentary
you've made reference and a number of
commissions
I might suggest
um far narrower
I didn't understand the question yes I
wasn't nodding so much
I think by inference we believe there
must be
a
bio biological security strategy
look to us that it has
been developed with some after action
thank you number but it it's been fed
into the
the system it's the biological security
strategy that
I know was fed into the the working
parts earlier
there we are so I think on Monday the
the government issued
published this paper UK biological
security strategy could we perhaps look
at page eight
on the right hand side of the page sets
out strategic framework the four pillars
of the response understanding preventing
coordination and over the page please
UK science-based health and life science
sector International
10.
could you zoom in so that we can read it
thank you very much
implementation plan in the short medium
and long term in relation to those five
doctrinal
understand prevent detect respond and
cross-cutting and there are a number of
prepare
had a chance to to look at this strategy
I appreciate it's any very recently been
published briefly have you been able to
take into account
reaching a final view in relation to the
recommendations that you've just been
talking about and and which will
continue to
all right so we needn't trouble
ourselves to to try to
put the two together and then see to
what extent
passage of time in this plan
do you understand
the bishop
I don't know what is to effectively
remediate
I mean I mean
jargon and not enough playing
communication but
maybe I need to be a scientist like
YouTube
it's time
you're obviously used to them
I mean I think there are some elements
of what we recommend that we've
and if it would be helpful we could
one and
because we've already dealt with the
first handful of points that you made on
not page 33 Nissan that is not paragraph
88.
20 version I apologize so paragraph 88
we also recommend that consideration is
given to the following
ensuring that action is taken from
learning points of regular simulation
exercises for known and unknown epidemic
threats
to what extent
in what way is the historical simulation
excise process
different
external to to the process
um there are regulation
regular
known epidemic threats
um
what action is
I don't think the new biological
security strategy really gives any
further reassurance on that is the
being conducted on a premised basis so
for example the planners will say in
this exercise we're dealing with an
outbreak of mars or we're dealing with a
influenza pandemic or we're dealing with
accordingly your suggestion is that
further and closer attention is given to
exercises which are based on presumed
unknown
the people who've set the exercise know
but the participants have to find out
what it is
um
and that that is a valuable exercise to
go through
all right that's very
scaling up diagnostic testing being able
to scale up case detection and contact
tracing early in an epidemic Flex
again laudable and very sensible
conclusions which which might readily be
drawn in a general sense
very much grounded in in that
um and the the point here is that acting
really important in in an outbreak
to be able to keep on on top of it and
keep
experience from other countries
highlights the need for control
authorities
and the way to do that to make sure
control is not lost is to have available
so that everybody can know whether or
not they are infected to have
if you are infected can be traced and
made sure that they isolate and then a
flexible approach to risk assessment uh
with the consequences of infection so
they're all
very sensible
recommendations but they all hang on the
need to ensure that if you lose control
you've got the wherewithal to get it
back and to be able to care for your
public
that's right and the other point there
is that there is
infamous
from outside of this country from
previous experience that can be drawn
upon
because the issue of I think National
Security and political leadership is
perhaps not one
for
pnei or a similar body that's the panel
to which I made reference earlier which
had been disbanded
I asked you
would be of reinstating that panel or a
similar body and and in fact you said
that whilst one could have a number of
different bodies on
bring all the information and learning
together perhaps at a level above it
do you think that there is a need for
this sort of body or is it a question of
bringing the intelligence
um
Eve does bring all those different
elements of
um
uh epidemic intelligence
and so we we welcome that seeing that
and I think that
well it's not entirely
go into that bio threats radar but that
bring together surveillance for
influenza and other respiratory viruses
with surveillance for other pathogens
with epidemic potential at present these
are treated separately by The Who in the
United Kingdom you mean that they're not
treated separately by The Who
together the different systems for
surveillance
those for influenza and those for other
pathogens make a difference
um the the biosecurity risks that there
are then
influenza is not
separate from the other infectious
agents that there could be
that treated by a different body with a
danger that there's no cross-talking and
no coordination
and to have a more cohesive review
would be beneficial
threats radar at least would coordinate
and synthesize influenza
typically respond to an epidemic with
good epidemiological surveillance
including genomic sequencing effective
engagement communication with Society
rapid launch of clinical trials
development of diagnostic tests vaccines
and Therapeutics
the diagnostic test side
um
in the covid pandemic as it happened
developed particularly a diagnostic test
and very rapidly
why do you say
could you respond with good development
of diagnostic testing and Rapid launch
of clinical trials
the issue with diagnosis
developed very rapidly for for covid it
was if you remember inaccessible
issues of the outbreak that the the
scale of
he responds in relation to clinical
trials
um were there not in fact a number of of
the pandemic the Valdez Missouri and so
on yeah
we need to get this better and more we
need to continue this we need to keep
this right
engagement
is that a general appeal to make sure
that there is always the represent level
of scientific expertise
born practical and research science in
order to be able to to make the right
decisions
yes I think in general this worked uh
pretty well within the covert epidemic
finally you refer on page 35 to
something that you described as a
community-based surveyor
a stronger Community community-based
surveillance system
uh currently
to an extent but to know how widely a
disease is circulating with a community
within the community
to be able to do that and
here is is that we should build
on these systems that we have at the
moment to have routine surveillance
going on in the community and indeed
since we made that record
for National statistics has set up a new
community-based
which is covered and respiratory
infection survey and we welcome that
because we we feel that
respiratory infections that's exactly
the area that we feel we should be
moving into with surveillance so that's
good and we're there to have been
20 of course the government would have
been able to understand far better the
extent of the spread the nature of the
transmission
that would have assisted it to be able
to respond as efficiently as possible
yes it would have given us a better
clearer picture rather than
that's clear thank you
my lady those are all the questions that
I intend to put
to
very much
um Milady you'll know from
the system in place and before
have the opportunity of identifying
areas that they wish the inquiry to
examine
whereby they may identify particular
questions which they would wish either
the inquiry to put or which they would
wish to put themselves you have
provisionally indicated already the
areas which Mr
in the future but on this occasion may I
invite you to formally give permission
to allow Mr Weatherby to put the
questions he wishes to put
um
and of course I'll be brief and there
are just three points my name's Pete
Weatherby and I'm
just three
um
brief areas two which have been touched
on but I've got a couple of
supplementary questions about
um can I take you back to your paragraph
88b
um and you've asked some questions about
this a few moments ago so this is the
point about learning from the
experiences in China and neighboring
Asian countries can I just
other countries we did you have in mind
Korea
Taiwan Singapore yeah Thailand perhaps
yes
um thank you and um
to either
um slow the
um entry
indeed um so that's what we're talking
about and
um then
um contact tracing to
um the spread of the infection with
of course limited the infection and
bought time until vaccines were
available yes
yes and
um that led to better outcomes in those
countries than might otherwise have been
the case
certainly in the initial wave yes yeah
thank you now um am I right that those
countries had developed those points
those
um
um policies
um because of SARS and MERS probably but
particularly SARS so they learned from
what had happened
before effectively
we ourselves don't have any direct
insights
experience with SARS of course your
experiences here can can you help us as
to why there wasn't similar learning in
the UK
I think because of their direct
experience of of having had large
serious outbreaks of of coronavirus yeah
whereas in this country it was very
small number yeah
yes
and um
finally on this point so that led in the
initial stages as you say to a better
and I think you then said that
um the committee didn't meet after 2018.
very early stages of the coronavirus
outbreaks I think 2020 was probably the
last time we met yeah
the Peter Hall beef the chair of nerve
tag and Miles Carroll from phe were also
on that
the prioritization committee yes yeah so
so the the point of it
um to uh
more seriously than had been in the past
was a real priority for
indeed yeah and and was your role and
the role of the others from the UK was
it as independent scientists with
expertise in this area or was there an
official
um element to it
I believe it's um an individual
appointment certainly in my case I
wasn't representing an organization as
such yeah
official bodies here so that that
learning can
Fast Track if you like into the process
now the initiative itself
was to try to read
pathogen and the time at which effective
tests and mitigations could be developed
is that right correct yes so in the
initiative itself it was referred to as
the urgent need for Accelerated research
um
by
different groups that would include
include industry right so it was part of
the initiative was there any
follow-through from the initiative in
terms of the report being referred to
member states so that they would take it
forward in an organized way
um as I recalled a process was that
having identified priority diseases
for development of
um a MERS vaccine or SARS diagnostic
test or whatever and
be encouraged to develop those and to
seek
there's an ad hoc follow through process
um
well the
all-interested parties whether they
responded to that would be their choice
yeah like
ensure that there was research and
development into these dangerous
pathogens
I suppose in a way that would add
another party
there
um I mean it might be that some
countries really don't have the capacity
to develop such tests
um
people to to develop those and not all
countries would be able to do it I would
certainly agree with you that the
National Public Health
individual Laboratories certainly that
would be sensible are you aware of any
actual UK action that followed from
um the 2018 report for example
um
a vaccine initiative that Miles Carroll
LED yeah
that were brought up I see so the report
would have fed into that yes that's very
helpful
um now
Point
um you
um mentioned the UK
um pandemic flu plan
um which based on the 2011.
there's an acceptance with flu
once the dangerous pathogen had emerged
would almost certainly fail so there was
a fatalistic
um you've mentioned that having a plan
that emerged isn't that a problem
where the plan is based on not having an
approach to slowing the transmission of
it
I think it is yeah and I I think
plan but one that is more generic for
respiratory infections that takes into
account different incubation periods the
reason why there's like fatalistic
attitude towards influenza
the case if you've got a longer
incubation period as we did with covid
which meant
to implement more of a plan to control
transmission
a recognition that you may be able to
slow transmission
I think now we've had three
uh plan for the future I think that was
harder when we just got the two rather
Divergent approaches yeah
kind of got the message about
um
would have been the SARS plan at least
initially and then modified as more
information came up thank you fine
Global Health security index can I just
take you back
to the independent who independent panel
for pandemic preparedness and response
on covid in 2021 I'll put it on the
screen if I may inq triple zero one
eight three five
team please
yeah yeah
I've got it in front of me so that
that's fine bottom of the um well bottom
of the text on page
a graph but across the circles with lots
of circles
um
to school country pandemic preparedness
and then we have this rather interesting
graph which I'm not going to go
page and we could have the next page up
please
um what all these measures have in
common
response and then it goes on to say why
and then towards the end of the the main
first part
real world stress situations
Etc so simple point we shouldn't put too
much store in these
wood I think
um
I think the lack of any correlation
there between the two was a surprise and
not what we would have anticipated
before the pandemic but
I think it's very important to get
across is that the Jee
the public health capabilities and
capacities within a country yes it's not
looking at the wider
the population inequity
service or care sector or policy or
political decisions that are made about
an epidemic
the narrow nature of what is being
scored in a GE that that's not reflected
highly on such a tour and that is a
certain amount of complacency and of
feeling that one is well prepared I
think
does should not lead us to say okay
we're good we can stop here yes thank
you very much those are all the
questions I have very helpful Mr worthy
thank you very much
further yes thank you my lady Professor
Whitworth doctor Howard thank you very
much
very well and 10 o'clock tomorrow yes
please
10 o'clock tomorrow please
thank you
foreign